Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Brittlav und hier ist der Freitag wieder eingeläutet worden und,
auch wenn's Weihnachten ist, wir berichten weiter in unserem Spezial Corona Weekly mit mir und mit Pavel, hallo Pabel.
Hallo Tim.
Von Weihnachten lassen wir uns hier nicht abhalten, oder?
Nö, ne.
In gewisser Hinsicht hat man noch ein bisschen mehr Ruhe und noch mehr Zeit als ohnehin schon, um irgendwie sich mal alles genauer anzuschauen, oder?
Na ja, ich also nicht nicht wirklich eigentlich ist es eher äh und verändert bei mir.
Ja, ich hatte auf jeden Fall eine sehr äh YouTube-Reiche äh Woche und habe mir wieder so alles Mögliche reingezogen. Dazu später mehr.
Ja und jetzt äh denke ich mal, können wir erstmal so ein bisschen Bilanz ziehen, wie wir das jetzt hier jede Woche machen
Also vielleicht für die Leute, die auch das erste Mal hier einschalten. Wir sind jetzt schon, glaube ich, fast bei der sechsundzwanzigsten, siebenundzwanzigsten Sendung äh zu dem Thema.
Das schon eine ganze Menge und ähm ja, versuchen also wieder mal
die Infektionszahlen, die Sterbezahlen und alle anderen Zahlen, die uns noch relevant erscheinen, einzusammeln, die insbesondere so Deutschland betreffen
und äh ja was uns darüber hinaus noch Interessantes so entgegengekommen ist, was wir an Feedback eingesammelt haben,
et cetera pp,
Ja und dann schauen wir doch mal, was wir so haben. Wir haben heute den fünfundzwanzigsten zwölften zwanzig zwanzig. AKA Weihnachten und.
Dass es dann KW zweiundfünfzig, also wir sind jetzt tatsächlich in der zweiundfünfzigsten Woche dieses Jahres. Wir haben dann also.
Dreiundfünfzig Wochen. Sozusagen dem wir uns dann anzuschauen haben. Ähm wie sieht's denn aus.
Ja, also erstmal gab's halt in der.
Vergangenen Woche so eine ganze Reihe von sag mal medialen Tole Soul Momenten wo äh dann.
Jetzt der mediale Mainstream und die Artikel eigentlich auf das einschwenken, was wir hier,
teilweise seit Wochen oder teilweise seit Monaten äh propagiert haben, äh nämlich, dass es wohl doch besser gewesen wäre. Früh.
Und schnell und hart zu reagieren und dass der Lokdown
Leid sich jetzt als großer Fehler herausstellt im Wesentlichen und äh ja in einem Artikel äh.
Im Tagesspiegel habe ich dann ein Zitat von freiherr von Logau gefunden.
Was ganz gut tatsächlich die Lage erfasst in Gefahr und größter Not bringt der Mittelweg den Tod und dass es äh leider.
Das ist der Barockdichter Friedrich Freiherr von Logau. So, der hat es schon einge.
Und äh das passt jetzt leider gerade äh irgendwie ganz gut und ähm.
Wir sollten also nicht nur mehr auf Wissenschaftler hören, sondern auch auf.
Auf dichter, ja.
Und Denker.
Denke die gut findet natürlich ähm bei Zitaten immer irgendwas Passendes, was äh auf jede Situation passt, aber ja.
Ja, die Zahlen fangen wir doch mal mit Deutschland an. So, wir haben jetzt.
Ja in der zweiten Welle sind wir jetzt so fast seit drei Monaten drin.
Und wir hatten ja,
erstmal fünf Wochen Anstieg, dann hatten wir so drei, vier Wochen Plateau dann hatten wir wieder drei Wochen Anstieg und,
jetzt haben wir uns so bei fünfundzwanzigtausend infizierten.
In sieben Tagen etwa äh wieder.
Abgebremst allerdings ja sind es nur jetzt.
Ein paar Tage eigentlich im Moment.
In den letzten sieben Tagen gegenüber den sieben Tagen davor die Zahl der Infektionen ungefähr um drei Prozent,
zugenommen, also es wäre ein R-Wert von irgendwo eins Komma null zwei, also.
Es wächst aber langsam im Moment und man kann nur hoffen, ähm.
Ja, dass sich das stabilisiert und die Zahlen zurückgehen,
Aber wir sind ja auch ja jetzt mitten in Weihnachten drin und wie sich das jetzt alles auswirken wird.
Muss man sehen.
Also eine Verbesserung äh kann ich daraus ja noch nicht so richtig ersehen, also vielleicht ist es der eher etwas zurückgegangen, aber das war's dann auch.
Nee, ja, wie gesagt, den ja in den ist es halt in den, in den letzten Tagen hat es sich so ein bisschen.
Gut, aber die letzten Tage sind natürlich auch Weihnachten und wir alle befürchten, glaube ich auch, dass wir hier äh eine unterrepräsentierung haben werden, weil die Leute unter Umständen sich nicht testen lassen, weil Weihnachten und so.
Ja, also die Zahlen,
haben gerade das Potenzial auch wirklich unzuverlässig äh zu werden. Wahrscheinlich wissen wir erst irgendwann im Januar wieder, wenn sich das Testregime,
oder ja die normale Arbeit wieder stabilisiert hat wahrscheinlich ist auch viel Hausarztpraxen, die geschlossen sind, wobei es,
auch keinen Überblick darüber gibt
wie viele Hausarztpraxen zum Beispiel geschlossen sind. Es war jetzt kein Mensch, weil es gibt kein zentrales Register, wo sich jetzt Ärzte melden müssten, wenn sie zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr zumachen. So, das heißt,
Das ist auch völlig unklar, dass da halt auch hinterher wissen.
Ja und ich höre halt auch immer wieder jetzt, also ich hatte jetzt im Freundeskreis gab's jetzt auch mal wieder äh Infektionen, nachdem irgendwie äh der eine sich äh infiziert hatte und dann die äh.
Partnerin sozusagen dann auch Symptome entwickelt hat und dann gab's dann so nach Rückmeldungen beim Gesundheitsamt. So ja bleiben sie mal zu Hause.
Der Testjahr irgendwie Test gibt's nicht. So beim Sommer zu Hause. Also da werden auch.
Das ist jetzt anekdodische Evidenz natürlich, klar, ne? Nur sowas will man eigentlich gar nicht hören,
Ja, man will ja eigentlich hören so, aha, es gibt hier ganz klare ich meine es ist sozusagen jetzt nicht so eine Vermutung und ich habe vielleicht eine Grippe, sondern irgendwie hier der Mensch, mit dem ich zusammenlebe, ist getestet worden, ist
positiv, hat auch irgendwie das volle Symptomprogramm und ist einfach mal so richtig dabei. Und bei mir geht's jetzt auch los,
dann fließt diese Person ja auch noch nicht mal in die Statistik mit ein. Also was soll denn das? Das ist mir einfach,
unklar, was das soll und letztlich zeigt es einfach nur, wenn jetzt eben auch nur anekdotisch, dass das.
Dass wir in so einer Situation der totalen Überforderung sind. Es ist einfach, es gibt da keinerlei Luft mehr nach oben und alle rudern nur irgendwie wild mit den Armen.
Mal auch auf die Testzahlen guckt, dann ist es so, dass wir vier Komma sieben Prozent mehr Tests gemacht haben in äh Deutschland.
Und äh sieben Komma sechs Prozent mehr waren positiv davon.
Und wir haben also äh dementsprechend wieder auch einen neuen Rekord jetzt bei der positiven Quote, elf Komma sechs sieben.
Man kann halt schon in etwa auch sagen, dass äh solange die positiven Quote steigt, steigen auch die Infektionen, ja.
Dass es äh haben bei dem bei den deutschen Testregimen einfach so, das heißt egal wie man's dreht oder wendet oder oder rechnet die Zahlen gehen bisher nach oben.
Zu der Zahl der Toten, äh, die hat sich jetzt in Deutschland.
Auch erstmalig seit.
Langem scheinbar stabilisiert.
Wobei wir eben auch hier in das Problem reinlaufen. Wir wissen nicht.
Das möglicherweise auch einfach nur an Meldeverzögerung liegt, aber eigentlich wäre es mal an der Zeit, dass sich da langsam was stabilisiert und.
Das sagen wir auf jeden Fall im Auge behalten. Ja was die Bundesländer angeht.
Ist nach wie vor Sachsen ganz vorne, Thüringen, Sachsen-Anhalt, Brandenburg, Berlin, Hessen, Baden-Württemberg sind so gerade in meiner Risikotabelle, die.
Kandidaten und ja Sachsen.
Liegt halt mit im Moment fünfhundertvierundzwanzig Fällen pro hunderttausend.
Ganz oben und entspricht halt rund ja einundzwanzigeinhalbtausend neuen Fällen alleine in Sachsen in den letzten.
Sieben Tagen und.
Es wächst auch, wobei wir stärkste Wachstum haben ja gerade in Sachsen-Anhalt, muss man sagen.
Das ist aber schon echt krasse Insiden, also Zwickausendsiebenhundertzehn Fälle auf hunderttausend, also ist auch viel.
Ja, es ist schon heftig. Genau und.
Auch alles so Bereiche wo wo auch das Gesundheitssystem auch nachhaltig überfordert ist, also wo es in den Krankenhäusern einfach schon will zur Sache geht und einfach keine Kapazitäten mehr sind, die schweren Fälle wirklich gut zu behandeln.
Und so die Rangfolge jetzt in meiner Risikoliste ähm.
Es äh Sachsen, Thüringen, Sachsen-Anhalt, Baden-Württemberg, Berlin, Brandenburg, Bayern. Das sind so die Länder, die im Moment schlechter sind, als der Bundesdurchschnitt.
Und ja selbst wie Mecklenburg-Vorpommern äh liegt bei einer Institz von einundneunzig als bestes Land. Alle anderen haben über hundert.
Ja so vielleicht.
Zu den Bundesländern nochmal ein.
Blick dann auf die aktuellen Landkreis Hotspots, die mit der höchsten,
weiterhin die sechs sächsische Schweiz Ostergebirge und Zwickau, so die sind mit siebenhundertzwanzig und siebenhundertzehn.
Neuerkrankungen in den letzten sieben Tagen je hunderttausend Einwohner ja gut dabei.
In meiner Risikotabelle führt allerdings Coburg gerade, weil es dort irgendwie vierzig Prozent neue Fälle gab, also mehr neue Fälle.
Vierzig Prozent mehr neue Fälle.
In den letzten sieben Tagen, als in den sieben Tagen davor und ja, das verheißt da nichts Gutes, obwohl.
Dort die Institution noch unter sechshundert liegt, aber das kann halt ganz ganz schnell nach oben gehen.
Und so richtig ja Landkreise, wo man sagen könnte, die sind kurvit frei oder da muss man sich keine Sorgen machen. Gibt es nicht wirklich.
So, vielleicht kann ich jetzt noch ein paar mehr Sachen.
Berlin sagen, weil ich da nämlich jetzt auch den Grafen aber jeweils versuchen kurz zu machen.
Ja Berlin als Vorreiter wäre nicht ganz so schön im Moment, weil in Berlin sieht es so aus, dass wir nach einem.
Langen und starken Anstieg.
Nicht so eine, ich sage mal, Toilettenartige, flache Stufe hatten, sondern es ging dann gleich wieder nach.
Um aber jetzt ja in den letzten drei Wochen äh wieder anzusteigen und.
Das ist also jetzt ein bisschen unklar, wie es in Berlin weitergeht gerade heute. Erster Tag äh.
Wieder, wo.
Zahlen runtergegangen sind, aber das täuscht mit ziemlicher Sicherheit, weil nämlich die meisten Bezirke gar nicht gemeldet haben heute in Berlin.
Ja beziehungsweise.
Gemeldet schon, aber äh beim Gesundheitsamt war halt niemand, also eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben Bezirke haben halt.
Heute beziehungsweise gestern an Heiligabend äh einfach ja.
Keine Meldungen entgegengenommen. So und.
Was jetzt so die Bezirke angeht ist gerade Pankow aktuell am Ende der Risikoliste und Reinickendorf ganz oben. Das ist.
Munteres Auf und Abgehüpfe nach wie vor, vor allem wegen Ausbrüchen in Heimen, weil das dann immer so clustermäßig kommt und die machen dann halt.
Sondern Welle, sodass das Wachstum nach oben schießt, aber dann, wenn dann nicht innerhalb von einer Woche ein neuer Ausbruch größerer in einem Heim kommt oder dann äh.
Sieht man halt zwischendurch mal sinkende Zahlen.
Ja Berlin weit einen R-Wert von wer um die eins Komma null sechs null sieben also etwas höher als im Bund.
Und ich hatte mir dann aus irgendwelchen Gründen, weil äh es gab.
Hier zu Hause in die Diskussion, was jetzt geht und was nicht, also ob man sich jetzt eigentlich offiziell.
Draußen mit jemand anderem spazieren gehen darf im Moment gerade.
Und ich glaube offiziell eigentlich nicht.
Also du darfst miteinander joggen, mit Abstand, aber irgendwie langsam nebeneinander hergehen, ist glaube ich nicht erlaubt,
Ansonsten, ja wo ich halt hinten übergefallen bin ist beim Thema äh Quarantäne, weil ich wollte jetzt eigentlich wissen
darf man denn jetzt in Brandenburg
nur noch Feuerwerk kaufen fahren oder nicht, weil in der Zeitung wurde erst gesagt, oh, das werden wir unterbinden, dann hieß es,
nee eher nicht, dann hieß es okay, wir unterbinden's jetzt, es ist jetzt verboten und ich wollte nur finden, wo ich denn das jetzt finde, wie ich denn jetzt in der Berliner Korona Schutzverordnung des
rausfinden kann und ich hab's ehrlich gesagt nicht gefunden, dass das verboten,
wäre so äh richtig, also aber der eigentliche Punkt war.
Es gibt eine Seite, die schon mal spezifiziert werden alles unter welchen Bedingungen in Quarantäne muss.
So, das ist schon mal eine ganze Menge, wenn man eine Seite braucht, da schließt man, glaube ich, schon eine Menge mit aus. Aber anschließend kommen fünf Seiten.
Ausnahmen, ja? Mein abgesehen davon, dass
sich da kein Mensch dran halten kann an äh so eine sechs Seiten lange Quarantäneverordnung mit tausend Ausnahmefällen und so. Das also das allein geht schon nicht, aber,
der Tenor eigentlich, den man da rausliest, ist man auch gleich schreiben können. In Quarantäne müssen nur Privatpersonen
gerade nichts Wichtiges vorhaben. So, das ist äh der der.
Tenor der Berliner Quarantäneschutzverordnung so und das hat mich halt auch schon richtig wütend äh gemacht, weil.
Ich meine eigentlich eher gesagt sollte das ja mindestens der Lokdown Medium sein, ja? Aber das,
Ganze ist dermaßen durchlöchert und auch unkontrollierbar, das heißt wenn wir jetzt feststellen, dass es keine Compliance.
Gibt, dann hat das sicherlich auch was mit,
dieser Schutzverordnung zu tun, die in sich inkonsistent und unlogisch ist und nicht verständlich und einfach mal komplett für die Tonne,
Also so kann man das meiner Meinung nach nicht machen.
Es ist einfach zu kompliziert.
Versucht's auch viel zu viel zu vielen Leuten recht zu machen und dadurch dass es das Schlimme ist, das wird ja dann noch schlimmer, weil.
Kann man jetzt glaub ich schon festhalten, wovon wir ausgehen, wir gehen einfach davon aus, der Januar ist einfach schon mal im Eimer. Also könnte vergessen, dass am zehnten Januar irgendwas Nennenswertes aufgehoben wird.
Ja äh abgesehen davon, dass ich vielleicht trotzdem die Schulen dann noch eröffnen und es noch schlimmer machen. Ähm.
Das halte ich mittlerweile für vollkommen ausgeschlossen, weil diese Einschätzung haben wir ja eigentlich schon länger, dass das äh sagen wir mal, wenn's gut läuft, ist, ist, ist Mitte Februar irgendeine Verbesserung in Sicht, aber wenn,
Wenn das die Regelung ist und zwar, damit meine ich nicht, wenn die Ausnahmeliste so lang ist, sondern wenn die Ansagen einfach so unkonkret sind und bleiben.
Dass eigentlich niemand weiß, was Phase ist. Mal kannst du wahrscheinlich jeden beliebigen Polizisten jetzt ansprechen auf der Straße und wenn du fragst, ja wer darf denn sich jetzt hier gerade aufhalten und wen nicht? Das wissen die nicht.
Ja, selbst. Ich meine, selbst Juristen, wenn du die fragst, äh,
wissen äh es nicht wirklich so ohne sich da erstmal ein äh zu arbeiten oder einzulesen, zu mal sich das ja auch wöchentlich ändert. Das ist ja das andere Ding. Ja.
Also das ist einfach äh ich meine, wenn man will, dass Leute den Regelungen auch folgen, dann kann man auch nicht so ein, so ein Chaos anstellen und ja, ne. Also.
Dass es alles nicht gut und vor allem,
In dem Zusammenhang äh auch noch, wird's vielleicht jetzt passen, wer in der letzten Sendung kurz einen Paper erwähnt, auch aus Karlsruhe, wo es darum ging, mit Hilfe von Drift
Analyse, äh die Auswirkung von,
Maßnahmen zu erkennen und da war so ein bisschen die Aussage äh eine der Kernaussagen, okay, in der ersten Welle hätte man einen Tag später die Schulen.
Zugemacht, hätten sich die Gesamtinfektionszahlen verdoppelt. Und das kam mir damals schon so ein bisschen.
Bemerkenswert äh vor und ich habe dann deswegen mal mir so einen kleinen Simulator gebaut, der die erste Welle so mit Parametern nachvollzieht, wo ich dann,
ein Haufen Parameter genommen habe, gesagt habe, okay,
vorher, dass es dann Zeitpunkt und Ausmaß der Intervention und dann,
Ganze simuliert und dann von Hand die Parameter so eingestellt, dass die auf die beobachtete Kurve der ersten Welle passten,
und dann bin ich auf fast bemerkenswertes gestoßen zu sagen bei meiner Hand Driftanalyse, die ich vorgenommen habe war der Knick, also wo wo der Virus angefangen hat,
weniger erfolgreich zu werden, wo irgendwas passiert ist, war der elfte, zwölfte März herum.
Sagen das ist der Zeitpunkt gewesen, wo R
den deutlichen Knick gemacht hat, wo was passiert ist und dann habe ich einfach mal geguckt, wie war denn die Nachrichtenlage
in der Zeit und das war genau das Wochenende, wo ein Schlag um Einschlag
medial kam, da war,
da gab's tausend Todesfälle in Italien mit allen möglichen,
Horrornachrichten da war Heinsberg grade in in aller Munde.
Und so, also wenn man sich einfach mal.
Anschaut, so und sich gucken elfter zwölfter März zwanzig zwanzig, wir da die Nachrichtenlage war, äh wenn man sagen, Halleluja und,
ausgerechnet da begann dann auch der Knick während die Maßnahmen erst zehn oder elf Tage später verabschiedet wurden, was.
Mich dann veranlasst hat jetzt zu spekulieren, dass möglicherweise ähm Nachrichtenlage.
Ein Faktor ist, der den größten Einfluss auf die Ausbreitung der Infektion hat. Anderen Worten die Politik,
folgt die Politik reagiert eher auf die Nachrichtenlage, das heißt die Logdowns.
Ja nachvollziehen dann, was sich in ganz vielen Köpfen aber bereits vorher stattfindet, weil ja es ist auch logisch, die äh Politiker sind ja auch nicht
irgendwie komplett andere Leute und die lesen natürlich auch
Zeitung beziehungsweise als Politiker kann ich aus eigener Erfahrung sagen, verfolgt man die Medien.
Viel mehr Medien wesentlich intensiver als normale Leute. Man kriegt halt vom Parlament Medienausschnitte und von der Partei Plus
guckt natürlich selber, was was los ist und wenn halt plötzlich ja.
In den Medien die Panik losgeht, dann geht auch in der Politik die Panik los und dann passiert auch was.
So kann man das äh in etwa sagen sie das so ein bisschen meine vielleicht etwas zynische These ist, dass.
In dem Moment, wo dann ja in den Medien dann wieder Bilder von äh,
Patienten auf.
Krankenhausgängen liegen, die nicht behandelt werden können und na gut, Kühlcontainer haben wir jetzt schon, also da gibt's ja in einigen Gegenden,
Landes schon äh auch Probleme mit äh ja,
äh Leichenhallen, dass die tatsächlich schon voll sind, aber ansonsten ist ganz offenbar noch nicht peinlich
genug. Aber dass man davon ausgehen kann in dem Moment, wenn sich dann wieder so eine Panikwelle
breit macht, dann gehen auch die Zahlen runter, beziehungsweise kann man fast sagen, ja wir hatten ja vor Weihnachten eigentlich jetzt schon sowas auch wie eine wie eine Panikwelle, auch mit sehr hoher Zustimmung zu harten Maßnahmen
so dass ich davon ausgehe, wenn meine These stimmt, dass die Zahlen jetzt erstmal vorübergehend runtergehen, aber
weniger weil halt neuer Logdown verabschiedet wurde, sondern äh weil halt ja.
Panik aufgekommen ist.
Oder noch aufkommen wird.
Ja und nochmal aufkommen wird, weil wahrscheinlich die Zahlen dann auch nochmal einen weiteren Anlauf machen werden, aber,
Das ist die Situation und vielleicht zu dem Paper sagt man sich da,
sagen muss, der Effekt, den die da gesagt hatten, Schulschließungen ähm einen Tag später, dass,
konnte ich nicht nachvollziehen, aber was man äh sagen kann ist, dass.
Wenn die Nachrichtenlage, These so zutrifft,
hätte das gar nicht so die große Rolle gespielt, ob die Politik jetzt früher oder später gehandelt hätte, weil,
die Reduktion schon eingesetzt hat, aber wenn,
Reaktion eben drei oder vier Tage später eingesetzt hätte, hätte sich die Gesamtzeile infiziert. Nach achtzig Tagen verdoppelt werden wir drei bis vier Tage früher in Panik verfallen, ähm hätten wir die halbiert.
So ungefähr und wenn man jetzt sagen bei Einzelmaßnahmen wie Schulschließungen aus,
diversen Studien so habe ich Zahlen, dass die mit fünfzehn bis dreißig Prozent
vielleicht beitragen könnten zu der fünfundfünfzig Prozent Senkung die wir damals hatten,
und ähm da es so vier Tage spätere Schulschließungen.
Würden wahrscheinlich in der Größenordnung von vierzig Prozent mehr äh Infektionen bringen.
Aber zusammengefasst, dass,
aus Karlsruhe ähm überschätzt die Auswirkungen von Schulschließungen, aber nichtsdestotrotz äh sind die.
Da und äh sind ja bemerkenswert entscheidend. Also,
wenn man zehn Prozent mehr Gesamtinfektion pro Tag spätere Schulschließung.
Oder anders ausgedrückt, Schulen hätten einfach früher geschlossen werden sollen und ähm sind sie dann halt nicht. Ja, letzten Endes alles eine Auswirkung.
Der späten Entscheidung
es hätte uns alles oder vieles äh erspart bleiben können, hätte man einfach im Oktober einfach mal Ratzefatze gesagt, zwei Wochen machen wir jetzt mal nichts
aber dafür war halt einfach dann auch nicht ja die Stimmung nicht da und ich glaube wenn die Stimmung nicht da ist in der Bevölkerung, dann hat man äh vielleicht vorher auch zu wenig Zeit damit verbracht.
So eine Situation im Raum hängen zu lassen, also es man hat sie, ich habe das Gefühl.
Man hat sich sehr viel besser darin gefühlt, eine rosige Zukunft äh vorauszusagen, dass ja schon irgendwie alles gut werden könnte. Und wenn es dann aber.
Wenn du dann trotzdem reagieren musst, dann denken alle so, ja was ist denn hier,
Wieso denn das denn jetzt? Ich dachte hier ist rosige Zukunft und Weihnachten sind wir alle schön beieinander und kuscheln wieder. Ja, dann kriegst du die Leute halt einfach nicht mehr gedreht, weil sie sich an diesen Gedanken auch schon so gewöhnt haben. Aber wenn du äh eher sagen wir mal die ganze Zeit alles mit.
Ja, also läuft ja läuft ja gerade noch so akzeptabel hier mit euch, aber ich kann euch sagen.
Wenn er so weiter geht, so, dann ist Ballschluss.
Weißt du, also ohne jetzt gleich was zu beschließen, aber zumindest schon mal so dieses, dieses Setting äh aufzumachen, zu sagen, so, ja, also eigentlich, eigentlich sind wir hier kurz vor der vor der vor der Vollkrise.
Reißt euch mal zusammen.
Ja? Das Verrückte ist, dass ja tatsächlich jemand guckt, tatsächlich ist sogar die Kanzlerin sich relativ frühzeitig bemüht hat und noch andere auch wie Karl Lauterbach oder so. Die wurden ja nicht müde oder wir.
Zu warnen. Das geht so nicht. Das führt in die Katastrophe und.
Dann auch die Schizophrenie, dass man solange der Herbst noch weit weg war, war die zweite Welle im Herbst, die große Welle in im Herbst war in aller Munde, aber je je näher der Herbst rückte
umso weniger wurde irgendwie die
große Welle im Herbst thematisiert so als als ob man angefangen hat bewusst woanders hinzugucken. Also wegzuschauen.
Fand einfach nicht statt. Herbst wurde in den Winter verschoben. Na ja, gut, also da können wir können wir natürlich jetzt noch viel äh klagen
Tatsache ist, jetzt haben wir diese ganze Weichei Nummer äh an der Backe und zwar sowohl die von dem gescheiterten,
überhaupt nicht lock dauern, also der verdient meiner Meinung nach noch nicht mal mehr diesen Lookdown-Leitstatus, ja? Das war eigentlich da ist überhaupt nichts
runtergelockt worden und sogar jetzt die Maßnahmen zu Weihnachten, also angeblich ist jetzt ein harter Lokdauer.
Okay, gut, wo, wo denn, ja? Also es äh äh kann ich leider nicht feststellen.
Gut, ich befinde mich schon in einem, was ich eigentlich nur in der Wohnung in meinem Studio und.
Wo ich alleine bin, ja? Und im Supermarkt bin, wenn's wenn's äh mal heiß hergeht und ich versuche sogar das schon zu vermeiden,
na ja.
Also ich versuch's auch zu minimieren, indem ich alle drei Wochen oder so mal einen Großeinkauf mache und dann auch sogar.
Nach Brandenburg äh äh raus bin äh zum Großeinkauf, weil dort äh Großlehrerladen war äh.
In der Gegend, wo wir sowieso hin mussten und ja.
Ja und ich bin jetzt irgendwie begeisterter äh Kunde von Hello Fresh geworden und das die Sachen einfach direkt äh anliefern, wobei die mittlerweile auch schon überrannt sind und den den Kunden schon irgendwie,
Geld dafür bieten, wenn sie äh möglichst nicht nochmal bestellen.
So schlimm ist es da schon. Gut, na ja zur Panik ähm gibt's aber jetzt äh gleich noch neuen Anlass ähm.
Die Zahl, die du vor vergessen hast zu sagen vorhin, obwohl du sie dir aufgeschrieben hast, die müssen wir jetzt aber nochmal reinbringen.
Ja.
Die Berliner die Berliner Zahl, die die muss jetzt eigentlich nochmal kurz äh fallen, bevor wir dann auf die Mutation kommen.
Genau, also äh seit dem zwanzigsten zwölften zwanzig zwanzig hat Berlin jetzt mehr Kowit-Fälle als China. Ähm sechsundachtzigtausend,
achthundertvierundachtzig zu sechsundachtzigtausendachthundertneunundzwanzig Fällen in China, also ja herzlichen Glückwunsch,
Berlin.
Wir haben jetzt chinesische Verhältnisse.
Chinesische Verhältnisse in Berlin. Genau, schön. Ja.
Aber nicht lange, also das äh die werden wir auf jeden Fall überschreiten und von daher tja ist äh die Frage, wie können wir uns da noch rausretten.
Bezeichnend war auch, weil ich das auch getwittert hatte, hat dann auch jemand bemerkt, dass ein Großteil der Reaktionen darauf war, äh aber die Zahlen in China kann man doch nicht glauben.
Das war so die Haupt, das war so äh eine der Hauptreaktionen so nach dem Motto, ja, ja.
Wenn man irgendwelche Zahlen nicht glauben kann, dann unsere.
Ja also.
Damals als es in China noch in vollem Gange war, habe ich auch die Zahlen in China regelmäßig mitgetrackt, dass Falls Sankt unser Vorbild.
Und äh irgendwann sind wir dann aber von dem Vorbild abgewichen, weil wir in China dann halt weiter draufgehalten hat und die Zahlen jetzt in den letzten Monaten,
So kann man sagen, hat China um die zwanzig Neuinfektionen pro Tag,
auf was eins Komma vier Milliarden fast glaube ich Einwohner äh die die jetzt äh haben. So.
Zu dem Thema äh kann ich äh gleich nochmal eine Sendung,
Planen, von der ich auch äh ursprünglich gedacht hätte, ich bringe sie hier noch im UKW-Kanal äh unter, hat sich dann aber anders ergeben. Und zwar habe ich im Lokbuch Netzpolitik zusammen mit Linus in der letzten Folge.
Mit äh Katharinen Thai gesprochen, mit der ich auch schon mal hier bei UKW über die Situation generell in China gesprochen habe
Und die ist nämlich gerade in Taiwan angekommen und hat mal ganz frisch aus ihren Quarantäneerfahrungen dort berichtet und äh wie es denn da so generell
derzeit zur Sache geht und da können einem schon so ein bisschen die Tränen kommen, wenn man hört, wie da Quarantänemaßnahmen.
Äh ernst genommen werden und umgesetzt werden und mit mit welcher Vehemenz daran gearbeitet wird, dieses Virus fernzuhalten.
Ja, ich weiß, Insel und so weiter, aber das ist auch nur ein Beispiel. Es gibt auch viele andere Länder in Asien, die bei Leibe keine Inseln sind und das gilt vor allem für China selber.
Genau. Vorbei, wobei auch sehr schöner äh äh Tweet auf meinen irgendwie Berlin China Zahlen vergleichbar kam dann ja aber äh Berlin ist ja schließlich auch keine Insel.
Genau. Wie China zum Beispiel, ne? Eine riesige, eine riesige Insel mitten in Asien.
Ja, also äh wen das interessiert, würde ich eine sehr informative, unterhaltsame äh Sendung, Lok Buchnes für Tick dreihundertvierundsiebzig kann ich an dieser Stelle äh empfehlen.
Kommen wir zurück zur Panik, denn ein bisschen Panik gab's ja dann doch äh weil wir haben eine neue Mutation. Der.
Ja oder technischer ausgedrückt, VUI Strich zwanzig zwanzig zwölf Strich null eins.
Hat die Medien ähm in Aufruhr versetzt, denn es äh wurde berichtet vom.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wer das erst verkündet hat, war es Boris Johnson oder war es mit Handcock, der Gesundheitsminister ähm auf jeden Fall äh hat die äh äh Regierung ähm Kenntnis gegeben, dass sozusagen eine neue Mutation gibt, wobei das jetzt ein bisschen Missleading ist
es gibt am laufenden Metermutation dieses Virus, das ist das, was Viren machen, die mutieren die ganze Zeit.
Nur man hat halt eine Mutation ausgemacht und ich glaube, dann spricht man dann auch schon wieder von einem neuen Typ, wenn so ein, so ein gewisser Schwellwert da äh bei den Mutationen überschritten wird oder ein zumindest ein anderes Verhalten nachgewiesen wird.
Oder eine andere Variante, da bin ich mir jetzt gerade in der Teminologie nicht so hundertprozentig sicher. Auf jeden Fall,
hat diese Art also diese Variante des des Desast zwei, Virus dazu geführt, dass wohl ganze Landstriche im,
hoher Geschwindigkeit davon übernommen wurden und daraus leitet man wohl auch.
Dass diese Variante des Virus eine höhere ähm Transmissibilität hat, also dass sie sozusagen in irgendeiner Form.
Sich so angepasst hat, dass sie sich noch schneller verbreiten kann, ja? Oder einen einen höheren
äh natürlichen R null Wert hat sozusagen, also noch ansteckender geworden ist, als es das ohnehin schon war.
Es gab da ein ähm.
Treffen einer entsprechenden Gruppe, die New and Emerging Resportory Virus Stretch Advisory Group heißt das ganz passend oder auch nervt,
Und die haben sich irgendwie äh getroffen und haben da eben ihre ähm Ergebnisse präsentiert und,
Konkret geht's da wohl auch um eine Mutation in diesem Spike-Protein, also in diesem eigentlichen Stachel äh
Protein, nicht, was man auf diesen Bildern, die man vom Virus sieht, sozusagen oben draufhängt und was ja auch unter anderem dafür zuständig ist, dieses Eindringen in die Zellen zu äh unterstützen.
Ja und man hat also gesehen, dass das Ding irgendwie eine höhere Wachstumsrate hat, also ungefähr einundsiebzig Prozent höher als die anderer Virusvarianten
Das bedeutet so für einen R eine Steigerung von null Komma drei neun bis null Komma neun drei, also es war dann glaube ich im Mittel von null Komma.
Sieben Prozent, das drückt sich glaube ich dann in diesen äh einundsiebzig Prozent auch aus, weiß ich nicht ganz genau. Ähm.
Ja, der CT-Wert bei der Detektion in der PCR ist irgendwie auch äh geringer, das heißt, das äh löst auch mehr Viruslast aus, was das wiederum ganz gut erklären würde. Also macht so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als ob der.
Diese Variante des Virus einfach besser eindringt in den Körper, sich dort schneller vermehrt und deswegen auch eben eine höhere Ansteckungsfähigkeit entwickelt.
Also man kann eher also aus den einundsiebzig Prozent hatte ich ja über einen Daumen äh geschätzt sind's ungefähr null null Komma fünf äh.
Auf den RWT obendrauf, was extrem viel ist, was äh sozusagen einmal komplett, also es ist mehr als der der Rückgang, der die.
Aktuelle Welle vorübergehend zum Stillstand gebracht hat. Ja, da sind wir ungefähr,
ja von eins Komma fünf auf eins runtergegangen, so
kurze Zeit, aus welchen Gründen
auch immer und also null Komma fünf zu holen, wenn man jetzt das Vergleich mit okay Schulen schließen bringt vielleicht null zwei bis null drei und
Sammlungsverbote bringen auch null zwei bis null drei und die haben wir ja aber.
Schon ausgeschöpft und wir haben also so richtig null Komma fünf haben wir nur in der ersten Welle geschafft, also so so sehr zu zu senken. Insofern ist das halt schon mal eine Katastrophe,
noch zu dem aber zu der ja genommen Charakteristik ist sind sogar auf dem.
Spike Protein, also in insgesamt erstmal sind's natürlich dreiundzwanzig Motationen durch die äh die neue Virusvariante charakterisiert ist. Ich meine,
Welche Zahl soll's auch anders sein, als die dreiundzwanzig? So und davon sind vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht, alleine auf dem Spike-Protein, das heißt, das ist halt dann schon.
Deutlich verändert, was wohl auch dazu führt,
diese genetischen Veränderungen, was ich jetzt nicht gedacht hatte, aber es ist so, äh dass natürlich die PCA Tests äh möglicherweise Wändemutation,
halt und der Primer nicht mehr da ist, weil er entweder.
Ist oder äh ersetzt worden ist durch was anderes, schlägt halt dieser Primer äh dann äh auch nicht an und damit gilt dann der Test potentiell als nicht positiv. Wobei.
Dann sagen uns das früh.
Viele der aktuellen Teste der meisten Tests drei verschiedene Primer benutzen und davon zielt dann einer auf das Bike-Protein und das hat man in England dann auch benutzt, um,
dann festzustellen, wie häufig die Variante vertreten ist, weil die nämlich tatsächlich dann eben auf,
dass normales Bike-Protein von der anderen Variante nicht angesprochen hat, das heißt, man hatte dann dafür sagen die zwei anderen Genabschnitte waren dann positiv
der Dritte nicht und wenn halt drei positiv waren, war es halt die alte Variante und bei zwei positiven hat man dann,
sagt, ist es jetzt die neue Variante? Es gibt natürlich auch Tests,
wie viele weiß man nicht, die im Einsatz sind, die nur auf zwei Genabschnitte testen. Und wenn da von einer jetzt auf ein Spike-Protein liegt.
Würde der Test erstmal offiziell als Negativ gelten, weil es sich um irgendwas anderes, eine andere Scorna-Virus oder so handelt und eben.
Neunzehn so, aber ich gehe davon aus, da das jetzt bekannt ist, dass das jetzt auch alle Labore wissen werden und dass diese Tests, die,
möglicherweise dann,
neue Variante überhaupt gar nicht erkennen oder nicht richtig erkennen, dass die aus dem Verkehr gezogen werden und dass man dann eben dasselbe macht wie bei uns auch, dass man anfängt zu schauen.
Den Testsocki sind da jetzt zwei oder drei Abschnitte positiv und dann.
Wir vielleicht mal Zahlen kriegen für diese neue Variante, wie sehr die denn verbreitet ist.
Ja, also äh diese äh Feststellung von von dieser Nerv Tech, die ist jetzt
ungefähr eine Woche her. Der Max jetzt SW Spik über Weihnachten nochmal neue Erkenntnisse gegeben haben, aber die haben halt erstmal gesagt so, ne, okay, also der Grund der höheren Übertragbarkeit, der ist uns jetzt nicht so hundertprozentig äh klar, ne? Also es gi
Mutmaßungen, aber gesichert ist was anderes. Wir wissen auch noch nicht, wie lange das unterwegs ist. Wir wissen auch noch nicht, ob das in irgendeiner Form tödlicher ist.
Das ist ja eigentlich auch so die Grundfrage, äh weil nur wer das Virus sich jetzt mehr verbreitet, sagt das ja nichts darüber aus, dass es auch automatisch gefährlicher ist. Hört man das, glaube ich, auch schon vor Monaten diese Feststellung,
Na ja,
Das ist das, was eigentlich Viren tun. Man kann auch davon ausgehen, dass die Corona Viren, die heutzutage vergleichsweise harmlose Erkältungen sind. Vielleicht, als sie das erste Mal das Licht der Welt gesehen haben, auch
viel schwieriger waren für Menschen. Dass das.
Krankheitsverläufe waren, die vielleicht auch tödlich waren und ja vielleicht auch im selben Maße, wie wir das jetzt mit Saaskopf zwei sehen. Äh die sich aber dann eben angepasst haben mit der Zeit.
Weil nicht, dass Birus will ja sozusagen überleben, das äh der evolutionäre äh Gang der Dinge
sprich äh eine höhere Transmissibilität,
klar, das ist natürlich im Interesse, ne, aber das hat ja auch was damit zu tun, dass man möglichst seine Host nicht äh zu schnell umbringt, weil dann hören sie ja auch auf, äh irgendwas weiterzugeben, beziehungsweise es werden dann halt entsprechende Vermeidungsstrategien gefahren, ja, äh,
ganz gut in China, so, da gab's jetzt keine weiteren nennenswerten neuen Varianten, äh nicht so gut eben in Europa und von daher ist es eben auch keine Überraschung, dass wir das jetzt äh ähm also
in Europa sehe, ich sage jetzt mal nicht in UK sehen, also klar, die haben auch viele Fälle äh gehabt, aber ist ja auch bei Leibe nicht die einzige Mutation, die es bisher gab oder keine nicht die einzige Mutation, die so erkennbar, schon wieder so eine eigene Variante darstellt
wenn ich's richtig sehe
wird derzeit so von drei großen neuen Typen berichtet von Saaskoff zwei. Da gibt's zunächst einmal in Südafrika.
Eine, die auch eine ähnliche Mutation ist, wie die UK, aber wohl nichts mit der zu tun hat, also da ist sozusagen an zwei unterschiedlichen Stellen der Welt eine ähnliche ähm Veränderung hat sich ähm,
also hat stattgefunden und hat sich auch durchgesetzt,
Und ähm dann gab's ja hier noch diese diesen Märzausbruch, das hat wohl auch, also in Dänemark, ja. Das nennt sich irgendwie Cluster Five.
Ist auch so eine eigene Variante, was wohl auch damit zu tun hat, dass in Herzen äh die Viren auch ideale Bedingungen finden, um da fleißig vor sich hinzumutieren.
Und jetzt äh eben diese UK-Variante, ne.
Das wird auch gemutmaßt, dass äh bei den neuen Varianten die Ausbreitung unter Tieren auch deutlich nochmal besser funktioniert, obwohl es eigentlich primär einen Menschenvirus ist.
Mhm. Okay. Die große Frage, die sich natürlich alle gestellt haben.
Greift der Impfstoff noch. Jetzt sind wir ja nun gerade soweit äh mit dem Impfen anzufangen. Also,
Heute haben wir den fünfundzwanzigsten, hier soll's in zwei Tagen am siebenundzwanzigsten losgehen in Berlin, in Deutschland überhaupt. Andere Länder impfen schon, wenn wir eh gleich nochmal drauf eingehen.
Da gibt's jetzt noch keine gesicherten Erkenntnisse, aber um das mal so ein bisschen in ähm Zahlen umzusetzen, dieses Bike-Protein, um das es ja geht und was ja für den Impfstoff quasi der Hauptangriffspunkt ist.
Hat so an die tausendzweihundertsiebzig Aminosäuren, die sozusagen erkannt werden können,
Also das ist so quasi die Genetik dieses Proteins und,
daran erkennt man dieses Protein und wenn man jetzt einen Impfstoff hat oder eben auch Antikörper äh hat, also das Immunsystem reagiert
muss ja irgendwas erkannt werden und es äh wird an diesen Aminosäuren, an der Kombination davon erkannt. Davon haben sich jetzt neun geändert. Und so ein Impfstoff.
Reagiert auch nicht nur auf eine einzige Stelle, sondern der hat mehrere Angriffspunkte, auf die er äh reagiert, wie das genau in dem Impfstoff ist, kann ich nicht sagen, aber.
Grundsätzlich ist es so, es ist jetzt nicht so, wenn da jetzt irgendwie ein Bit umkippt, dass dann äh äh alles aus dem Ruder kommt und der Impfstoff ist wohl auch schon mal gegen andere Varianten, also oder zumindest gegen andere Mutationen, immer mal wieder getestet worden.
Und bisher hat äh das Erkennungsschema, was man sich eben für diesen Impfstoff ausgedacht hat, also ich rede jetzt von diesen Biontech äh im Stoff, ne? Der einzige, der jetzt äh zugelassen ist. Ähm bisher hat es halt auch immer noch funktioniert.
Und das war noch so eine Aussage von dem Shayin, der äh mit dem Chef da, dem.
Gründer von Björn Tech, er meinte so selbst, wenn jetzt eine Variante käme, die irgendwie.
Diesen Impfstoff vermeidet, die also in irgendeiner Form so stark motiert ist, dass der Impfschoff auf einmal blind wird.
Ja oder sagen wir mal nicht die richtigen Antikörpererzeuger erzeugt ja quasi äh also dem der Impfstoff,
geht ja in die Zelle und sagt der Zelle so, produziere jetzt mal genau dieses Protein, damit der Körper darauf reagieren kann, dagegen äh eben das Immunsystem hochfahren kann. Wenn dann eben.
Dieses Bike Protein.
Anders aussieht des Virus und das Immunsystem nicht mehr drauf reagieren kann, da hat man halt Pech gehabt. Aber das ist das Schöne an diesen RNA-Impfstoffen.
Das ist letzten Endes im Prozess ändert sich da relativ wenig. Die ändern sozusagen einfach dann die die Kodierung. Er meinte, das wäre dann innerhalb von sechs Wochen
würde man dann schon wieder Impfstoff produzieren, der das auch berücksichtigt. Also da kann man sozusagen nachfahren und da muss man jetzt irgendwie keine
Ja, keine Bedenken haben, also das denke ich mal ist nichts worüber man beunruhigt sein sollte.
Ja, hätte ich auch so angenommen, dass solche Impfstoffe eher ähm,
einfach anpassbar sind ähm wobei ich mich dann aber auch noch frage, was.
Natürlich erworbene Immunität ist, ob sagen auch,
volle Kreuzimunität zwischen alten und neuen Virus besteht. Das heißt, wenn man schon mal Corona alt durchgemacht hat, ob man dann auch genauso gut gegen jetzt äh
Corona You Kun ist vermutlich ja, aber darüber habe ich noch keine Aussagen gefunden und
der Mechanismus könnte natürlich ein bisschen auch von ihm abweichen wie das jetzt bei der Impfung passiert, die die.
Immunisierung, weil äh sagen auf welche Proteine sich jetzt dann das Immunsystem.
Einschießt beim echten Virus, dass mh.
Ist jetzt keine standardisierte Immunantwort, sondern was der Körper im Prinzip macht ist der macht da so,
bisschen auch ja äh genetisches Engineering eigentlich das Immunsystem und hat so eine Antikörperzuchtanstalt, wo es dann äh verschiedene Varianten von Antikörpern ausprobiert
dann diejenigen, die gut funktionieren, dann äh ja weiterverwendet und so dann irgendwann,
sich selber quasi sein seine Antikörper entwickelt, äh, wenn man so will und,
welche Antikörper, äh, aber wie die genau strukturiert sind und auf welche Proteine die dann gehen, kann sich natürlich unterscheiden von äh dem, was äh bei der Impfung passiert, aber
quantifizieren kann ich das nicht. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass das kein,
Problem äh äh ist aber äh Information dazu habe ich jetzt noch nicht gefunden,
dem auch so ist.
Also ich denke, es gibt auf jeden Fall genug Grund in der äh Geschichte erstmal entspannt zu bleiben. Also da äh habe ich jetzt noch nichts gesehen.
Wo die Wissenschaftler total in Panik ausgebrochen sind, sondern es wird allgemein angenommen, dass sowohl der Impfstoffgrad als eben auch noch die Immunreaktion der Leute, die es schon gehabt haben,
ist es halt eine Mutation. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass wir es mit was komplett neuem zu tun haben und aus den verschiedensten Gründen,
Zahlen haben wir ja genannt, äh denke ich mal, liegt das auch noch relativ nah bis äh wir Besseres zu tun haben.
Also auf die Ausbreitung in Deutschland zumindest dürfte es kurzfristig auch keine,
Auswirkungen haben. In London hat es glaube ich um die drei Monate gedauert, bis äh diese neue Variante sich dann zur dominanten Variante entwickelt hat und,
in UK. Insgesamt ist es auch immer noch nicht die dominante Variante. Das heißt,
wahrscheinlich ist es äh aber eher ja langfristig ein Problem und äh nicht kurzfristig.
Ja, kurzfristig hat es auf jeden Fall ähm die Grenze ähm,
Vereinigten Königreichs äh torpediert kurz vor Brexit, hat man dann schon mal so no Deal
Brexit äh Situationen gehabt, weil dann auf einmal Tunnel und fair Betrieb eingestellt wurde und die ganzen Lastwagen nicht mehr rüberkam. Das war natürlich auch nicht so schön, insbesondere nicht für die Lastwagenfahrer,
Äh aber man wollte halt jetzt hier irgendwie mal Aktionismus machen und ähm das vielleicht auch erstmal nicht so schlecht. Ähm nur.
Hast du ja schon auch die Frage gestellt, na ja.
Wo ist sie das jetzt sozusagen über Halt und wo ist es denn vielleicht schon hin? Weil es gibt ja Flugverkehr. Es gibt ja Reiseverkehr. Wir haben ja schon gesehen, wie super das mit den ganzen Quarantänemaßnahmen so funktioniert. Ähm,
Und da kam natürlich dann die Frage auf, woher wissen denn die Briten das eigentlich so gut? Und stellt sich raus äh also für mich äh.
Großbritannien ist auch ganz weit vorne in der Sequenzierung,
deservieren. Ähm wir hatten das vorletzte Sendung, als ich mal das Programm von äh Island und äh in gewisser Hinsicht auch Neuseeland vorgestellt habe, dass hier massiv sequiziert haben. Also, dass sie nicht nur festgestellt haben
Oh, da ist jemand positiv, weil wir haben jetzt hier einen PCR-Test gemacht und du hast hier jetzt Corona-Virus eingefangen,
haben wir dann eben dieses Sample auch noch genommen und wirklich genetisch auseinandergenommen, also eben sequenziert und sich mal genau angeschaut, genau, was hast du denn da einen für drin? Gibt's denn da irgendwelche Mutationen? Und dieser Sequenzierungsvorgang, der da in Island extrem gemacht wurde,
Der wird auch in Großbritannien relativ äh gut gemacht und es gibt sogar noch Länder, die noch viel weiter äh vorne weg sind.
Gibt da eine schöne Übersicht auf Kuwit C G Punkt org, wo mal so die Top Ten äh äh hier vielleicht mal vorgelesen werden sollte
Sequenzierung pro eintausend Fälle, ja? Also wer macht wie viele Sequenzierungen bei, wenn man das jetzt mal gegenrechnet gegen tausend neue Fälle.
Oder auf Platz eins ist der Australien mit vierhundertneunundsechzig Fällen.
Vierhundertneunundsechzig Sequenzierungen pro Tausend Fällen Neuseeland, dreihundertsechsundvierzig.
Dänemark dreiundneunzig eins, die mit den Nerzen.
Dann kommt Island mit einundneunzig drei, das hat mich jetzt ein bisschen gewundert, weil sich das ja sozusagen aus diesem Bericht so rausgelesen habe, dass sie sich bemüht haben,
nahezu alles zu sequenzieren, aber zum vielleicht galt das sozusagen nur für diese erste Phase, bin ich mir jetzt nicht so hundertprozentig sicher.
Dann kommt Gambia mit sechsundsechzig Komma acht. Taiwan, schon erwähnt, sechzig Komma drei, dann äh UK fünfundfünfzig neun Japan, sechsundvierzig drei.
Thailand, zweiundvierzig zwei und dann kommen noch ganz viele andere Länder und dann kommt irgendwann Deutschland mit null Komma vier sieben drei. Ja, also wir schaffen's gerade mal vier bis fünf von zehntausend Fällen.
Sequenzierung zu machen, wo man sich dann denkt so äh aber ich dachte, wir sind hier die.
Sind hier die totalen super Virologen alle was geht.
Ja, also ich sehe da null Komma sieben neun zwo, weil Deutschland Sequenzes per Pausencases auf Kowic CG Punkt org.
Aha hat sich vielleicht die Zahl gerade geändert, jetzt.
Aber.
Ich hatte mir das notiert, okay? Dann gehen wir mit null Komma sieben. Ist immer noch zu wenig.
Ist immer noch, also null Komma sieben neun im Vergleich zu ja fünfhundert bei den Spitzenländern, also dann sagen die.
Äh testen, sagen wir mal mindestens fünfhundert Mal so viel wie wir.
Nicht testen, sequenzieren.
Sequenzieren sorry ja sequenzieren, also testen und sagen, dass das Genom oder ermitteln, dass Genom.
Des Virus und welche Montationen dort vorliegen.
Und dann äh ist die Frage, okay, wie viel sind es denn pro Tag, wenn man das dann umrechnet, stellt man fest, das sind,
in Deutschland ungefähr fünf pro Tag so, ja
also fünf Sequenzierungen pro Tag, je nachdem maximal sind's zwanzig, weil man weiß auch nicht genau, wie die Zahlen zustande gekommen sind, aber es gab auch die Aussage, dass bisher ungefähr seit Beginn von Co.
Und äh Kovit in Deutschland nur ungefähr tausend Sequenzierungen insgesamt vorgenommen worden.
Plus was noch dazu kommt, wir brauchen zwei Monate, um die Ergebnisse dann zu melden an ähm ja die Weltgesundheitsorganisation beziehungsweise die
Gruppen, die sich damit beschäftigen, dann äh weltweit äh die Gensequenzen zusammen zu
tragen, also wir sind wie gesagt ein miserabler Player und.
Allein schon hundert Mal weniger als Thailand oder Japan oder UK äh oder nur ein Hundertstel von dem. Und.
Die Frage, äh die,
gestellt habe, okay was bedeutet denn das jetzt generell für die Erkennung neuer Virusvarianten,
wie weit kann sich denn so eine neue Variante, wie dieser englische Virus in Deutschland eigentlich ausbreiten bevor,
bei unseren Sequenzierungen mit einer gewissen Wahrscheinlichkeit,
auftaucht und da hatte ich dann auch noch auf äh Twitter, um Hilfe
beten, ob der nicht jemand Lust hat, äh das mal auszurechnen und dann äh hat sich ja dankenswerterweise äh Frau Stahlhut.
Bereit erklärt und hat ein schönes Geogebraplet äh gemacht, dass man auch interaktiv aufrufen kann mit ein paar Slidern, wo man sich diese Wahrscheinlichkeiten errechnen kann und.
Ja wenn man jetzt.
Sich die aktuellen Zahlen äh tatsächlich anschaut, dann ist es so, damit wir innerhalb eines Monats.
Jetzt eine fünfzigprozentige Wahrscheinlichkeit haben, eine neue Variante zu erkennen,
ähm brauchen wir über hundert Fälle pro Tag dieser neuen Variante. Also alles, was irgendwie weniger als hundert Fälle hat, braucht hal,
entsprechend länger oder wird halt ähm ja mit einer geringeren wahrscheinlich einen Wind,
sagen Ziel, wenn wir jetzt sagen, wir möchten's gerne innerhalb eines Monats eine neue Variante zu neunzig Prozent Wahrscheinlichkeit finden, dann müssten wir dreihundertachtzig Fälle,
dieser neuen Variante am Tag haben, damit wir sie auch sicher erkennen. Wenn wir jetzt umgekehrt sagen, okay.
Wenn wir jetzt ähm sag mal eine möglichst niedrige aber schon sinnvolle, ich sag mal täglich vier Fälle.
Von einem von einer neuen Variante würde durchaus naheliegend, dass die eine gewisse Verbreitung erfährt und wir wüssten natürlich auch gerne,
zu neunzig Prozent innerhalb eines Monats, davon, wenn jetzt so eine neue Variante sich auf den Weg macht, dann müssten wir pro Tag fünfhundert Proben,
was ja äh ziemlich genau dem hundertfachen von dem.
Entspricht was wir im Moment tun und möglicherweise machen UK, Japan und Thailand eben genau.
Das nämlich hundert Mal so viel zu sequenzieren und ja also mit anderen Worten ähm.
Bevor wir,
bei den aktuellen Sequenzierungsmethoden irgendeine neue erfolgreiche Virusvariante entdecken muss, die mit einer äh Institanz ja.
Von.
Ich sage mal, vierhundert Fällen pro Tag in in Deutschland auftreten gerade und das heißt, ja, das ist komplett absurd, man kann also sagen, eigentlich bei der geringen Sequenzierungsrate haben wir,
so gut wie keine Chance, also eine extrem geringe Chance, neue Virusvarianten,
zu finden bei uns, äh die, egal ob sie, wie gefährlich sie jetzt sind oder nicht, äh bis wir sie finden,
ist es zu spät um irgendwas dagegen zu unternehmen. Das kann man halt einfach mal konstatieren bei uns und ich,
weiß auch nicht warum, ich verstehe nicht warum hast du irgendwelche Informationen warum wir uns auch im internationalen Kontext so schweinisch verhalten und da nicht,
zu der Sequenzierung.
Also ich kann's nicht sicher sagen, was ich so rausgehört habe, was ich so meine, rausgehört zu haben, ist das ein
Problem, dass es einfach die Kapazitäten dafür gar nicht gibt und das es hängt dann wieder eben mit der äh Förderung der akademischen Forschung in dem Bereich zusammen. Also es sind einfach schlicht diese Mittel
so nicht investiert worden, um dafür die notwendige Kapazität aufzubauen. Deswegen sieht es auch in UK ganz anders aus, weil das da eben durchaus ein Fokus war,
Also es ist einfach in diesem genetischen äh wissenschaftlichen Bereich,
sehr viel mehr Geld in die Forschung geflossen ist, was letzten Endes zum Aufbau entsprechender Labore auch geführt hat. Das ist jetzt eine völlig.
Daher gesagte Feststellung, dafür habe ich jetzt keinen passenden äh äh Link mehr, weil ich das äh so aus so
Zitaten und und Kommentaren rausgehört habe, ohne mir jetzt groß was in dem Moment dabei gedacht zu haben oder mir das notiert zu haben. Das mag so sein,
Das weiß ich nicht, hundertprozentig, aber es ist jetzt nicht nur ein,
Dingen, wo man jetzt sagen kann so, ach ja, mehr Sequenzieren, dann drehen wir doch mal diesen Regler hoch, das das kriegen wir sozusagen jetzt auch nicht so ohne Weiteres gefixt, weil's,
einfach schlichter die Infrastruktur nicht vergibt.
Aber äh fünf Fälle am Tag ich.
Ja? Ich verstehe es nicht gut, wahrscheinlich, weil jetzt nicht auf die Suche nach einem schuldigen macht, dann wird wahrscheinlich das Gesundheitsministerium, das Forschungsministerium schieben sich das dann hin und her, so nach dem Motto, ja, diesen, ja, aber auf jeden Fall sich, ich
äh dachte ja, mich könnte so mich könnte nichts mehr erschüttern äh so, aber äh dass dass.
Ich halte das für 'nen absoluten Skandal, so dass für 'n für 'n komplettes Versäumnis und.
Ich ja, ich ich kann's nicht verstehen, wie man da so pennen kann. So oder es so, ja.
Prioritäten. So, ich meine man hat halt andere Prioritäten gehabt und so äh ist es halt, ich meine, es ist jetzt nicht unbedingt so, dass jetzt.
Kein Geld in wissenschaftliche Forschung fließen würde in Deutschland, man kann aber immer noch drüber argumentieren, dass es zu wenig ist,
wenn man sich anschaut, wie das da so mit Stellen und so weiter,
so läuft, da bin ich auch kein Experte zu und ich denke an der Stelle können wir da jetzt auch nicht sehr viel mehr zu sagen, außer, dass wir das ganz allgemein anprangern und äh uns wünschen, dass wir da Sequenzierungsweltmeister werden innerhalb der nächsten Zeit.
Wollen ja immer in allem Weltmeister sein. Warum nicht dann auch in der DNA äh äh Sequenzierungen RNA Sequenzierung muss auch sein.
Also das ist ja eigentlich ist es ja aber auch, dass wenn mal Urstammhauptgebiet von Professor Drosten.
Ja, der kann das ja auch machen, aber die Frage ist, wie viele Labore hast du und wie viele Leute hast du in Lohn und Brot, die sich eben auch mit solchen Sachen konkret beschäftigen? Also ich meine, muss ja da sozusagen auch äh das muss ja dann auch organisiert sein, da müssen ja diese Proben,
von Tests, die in Labors genommen werden, müssen ja dann auch durchsequenziert werden. Also im Prinzip wäre das was etwas, was an den Lappen in den Laboren, wo die Tests gemacht werden. Ich bin mir nur nicht so sicher, ob
jetzt die Proben, die da eingehen, auch automatisch ja, müssten sie eigentlich.
Also in in England, in England haben die das so organisiert, dass die ein paar große Labors,
genommen haben und sich da dann direkt reingehängt äh haben, also so wie du sagst, das ist so wie die Engländer es gemacht haben. Ein paar ausgewählte Labore, die,
die größte Zahl an Tests äh verarbeiten. Dort gibt's dann auch gleich die Sequenzierungs ja Technik oder Stationen oder wie auch immer äh sind da dann gleich mit angehängt und,
Ähm ja, so kommen die dann auch äh immer an frische Varianten aus dem ganzen Land.
Ja
Vielleicht zu ein paar freundlicheren Themen denn es wird ja geimpft.
Zwar noch nicht in Deutschland, wie schon erwähnt, aber es wird äh auf der Welt geimpft in einigen wenigen Ländern.
Und da sei an dieser Stelle mal wieder ein weiteres Mal auf Hour World in Data verwiesen, haben wir zwar letztes Mal schon gemacht, als ich diese ganzen Bexine-Tracker vorgestellt habe.
Unter anderem war dann eben auch diese neue statistische Veröffentlichung auf Auerwald Adata dabei
wo dann jetzt mal gezählt werden soll, wie viele denn eins schon getestet wurde und jetzt ist ja mal wieder eine Woche vergangen.
Geimpft, weißt du? Die geimpft nicht getestet.
Geimpft. Ja natürlich. Äh.
Getestet.
Ja das Begriffe geimpft. Genau, also jetzt geht's hier wirklich um die äh tatsächliche Impfung von Leuten, also die Produktion von Impflingen und ja.
Zahlen, gucken wir mal drauf. Aktuell sind in der Welt drei Komma drei eins Millionen Impfdosen verabreicht worden,
Ja, es sind also Dosierungen, da ist es nicht Personen, aber da wir uns ja noch in den ersten zwei Wochen befinden.
Ist es quasi auch equivalent zu Menschen. Ja und äh das sind dann.
Wenn man das auf auf Menschen dann hochrechnet null Komma null vier Prozent der Welt.
Also das reicht jetzt noch nicht so ganz. Ganz weit vorne ist Baran mit zwei Komma neun vier Prozent, also die sind sozusagen schon drauf und dran sich äh durchzuimpfen.
Israela zwei Komma vier Prozent und UK eins Komma eins acht Prozent der Bevölkerung.
USA ist bei null Komma drei Russland bei null Komma eins vier, Kader null Komma elf.
China null Komma null sieben, also da wird auch schon ordentlich getestet getestet. Da wird schon ordentlich geimpft. Eine Million haben die auch schon das Volk gebracht, aber wir haben ja schon gesagt, eins Komma vier Milliarden Einwohner, das dauert eine Weile.
Also im Wesentlichen kann man auch sagen, von hin drei Komma etwas Millionen Impfungen wurden jeweils so rund ein Drittel in den USA, China und UK durchgeführt UK zweihunderttausend weniger, aber.
Genau.
Aber das sind Momentaufnahmen, das wird äh schnell vorangehen und ich bin mir eigentlich auch relativ sicher, das wird auch in Deutschland relativ schnell vorangehen. Wir haben ja für dieses Jahr eins Komma was war das? Eins Komma vier Millionen Dosen zugesagt bekommen.
Milliarden, nee, nicht äh ach so für ja eher. Mhm.
Dieses Jahr für zwanzig zwanzig insgesamt dann hoffentlich deutlich mehr, aber das ist sozusagen das, womit man jetzt an Start geht, wenn die ganzen Impfzentren aufmachen übermorgen. Ja, dann muss man gucken, wie gut das läuft, ne.
Ja, gut, das wird haben wir, glaube ich, vor dem letzten Mal schon gesagt, ich gehe davon aus, dass es erstmal.
Nicht ganz so schnell äh anläuft, aber dass das dann wahrscheinlich so ja Ende März ab April so dann richtig.
An Geschwindigkeit aufnehmen müsste und ja Ziel und das ist zumindest was ich auch von.
Impfstoffherstellern gehört habe, dass das realistisch ist, dass man halt vor dem Herbst.
Gerne durch sein möchte mit einmal durchimpfen und dass das wahrscheinlich auch erreichbar ist. So das war ein bisschen auch die.
Große Frage.
Wie lange wird's denn dauern, weil da so ja die Rede war von gut einige Länder kriegen vielleicht erst zweitausenddreiundzwanzig oder vierundzwanzig den Impfstoff, was ich für ja übertrieben halte, aber.
Ja, wir werden sehen. Wir werden sehen, aber im Moment ist das Ziel eben ja, dass bis zum Sommer alle durchgeimpft sind, zumindest die wollen.
Wobei nach Umfragen ja jetzt dann äh die Bereitschaft sich impfen zu lassen in Deutschland,
angeblich abgenommen hat, hast du da was drüber äh gehört.
Also ehrlich gesagt, ich gebe da nicht viel drauf. Ja, jetzt ist das neu,
jetzt äh haben alle erstmal noch ein bisschen Angst und wissen nicht so genau und äh man hört zwar was davon und äh Berichte über irgendwelche Nebenwirkungen sind natürlich jetzt erstmal ein heißes Thema und die werden dann so ihrer äh Folger äh zeigen.
Aber das kann halt auch genauso gut wieder umschlagen. Was ist, wenn jetzt die Achtzigjährigen alle geimpft sind.
Ja, in den äh in den Altenheimen, da gehen ja jetzt hier mobile Teams in die Altenheime rein und impfen die äh durch. Ja, das das könnte so im Februar abgeschlossen sein.
Wie viele Tote werden wir dann noch sehen? Im achtzig Plus Segment. Wie wird sich das dann ändern, wenn im siebzig Plus Segment alle geimpft sind.
Das kann sehr gut sein und das ist auch ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen meine Erwartung, dass wir dann einfach enorm gefallene Todesraten haben, ja.
Das auf jeden Fall.
Das ist so, da wird's bei manchen wird's noch ein bisschen zu spät kommen und so weiter und äh äh es wird vielleicht auch noch irgendwelche.
Konditionenbedingungen, Situationen geben, die wir so noch nicht absehen können, wo der Erfolg vielleicht des Impfstoffs in irgendeiner Form eingeschränkt ist durch irgendwelche.
Kreuzreaktion, was weiß ich, ja, wo.
Vielleicht auch die Impfung selber oder oder so äh nochmal ein Problem äh herstellt. Wir haben das ja gesehen mit Leuten, mit Allergien et cetera.
Aber ich gehe schwer davon aus, dass wir dann einfach in diesem Altersbereich, der dann geimpft ist.
Keine Probleme mehr sehen und dann wird die Meinung sich auch ändern können und wird sie sich wahrscheinlich auch ändern. Hier alte, schwache Leute, wo normalerweise ja die Erfahrung eher ist, Impfstoffe schlagen da nicht so gut an.
Na, man braucht höhere Dosierung, es dauert länger und äh die Wirkung ist nicht so optimal. Wenn sich halt das zeigt, was ich bisher in den in den Phase drei Studien gezeigt hat.
Werden wir einen durchschlagenden Erfolg haben von fünfundneunzig Prozent und äh ja, wenn dann die Todeszahlen auf einmal runtergehen und es dann auf einmal nur noch die Fünfzigjährigen, sind die sterben,
Dann werden sich das die Fünfzigjährigen überlegen, ob sie nicht vielleicht auch mal probieren sollten, äh ob so ein im Schoff nicht vielleicht helfen kann.
Ja, also faul sagte irgendwie, man bräuchte aber neunzig Prozent der Bevölkerung damit man wirklich Herdenimmunität äh hat jetzt.
Klar, dass die Infektion äh zurückgeht. Das ist ja das eine, aber die, dass erstmal die Sterblichkeit runtergeht. Ich meine
angenommen wir hätten jetzt die siebzig und Achtzigjährigen schon durchgeimpft und wir würden die mal rausnehmen aus unseren täglichen Todeszahlen, dann würden wir nicht von knapp tausend Leuten äh reden, sondern vielleicht nur noch von fünfzig.
Eher so ja ein bis zweihundert, aber.
Oder hundert oder also auf jeden Fall nennenswert anders, ne.
Definitiv, das die geht dann äh definitiv äh ziemlich schnell runter die Todesrate.
Guter Punkt, ne? Äh die Angst vor.
Schäden. Wie das immer so schön heißt, so Impfschäden oder Langzeitfolgen da habe ich ein äh einen ersten schönen YouTube äh Tipp für euch.
Und zwar äh aus dem Projekt mega make Europe gescheit,
hören könnt aus Österreich,
da referiert jemand namens Martin Moder, er gehört zu den EU Missbastas, Wissenschaftler und äh macht sehr unterhaltsame Videos dem ganzen Thema.
Unter anderem, dass es dann auch verlinkt ein Video was sie mit dieser Frage mit den sogenannten Langzeitfolgen von Impfungen auseinandersetzt,
Und äh klärt da mal so ein bisschen die Begriffe, weil das ist ja sozusagen so ein, so ein, so ein Mythos, ne? Ja, Impfen und so, da weiß man ja nicht, das kann ja auch noch später.
Später irgendwelche Auswirkungen haben und nur weil jetzt noch nichts passiert ist oder weil jetzt in diesen Phase drei Studien nichts passiert ist und es ist ja im Wesentlichen nichts passiert. Also es gab halt die üblichen Seiteneffekte.
Also Muskelschmerzen und so weiter, die im Prinzip ja nix anderes sagen als.
Es ist genau das passiert, was wir hier eigentlich beabsichtigt haben, nämlich dein Immunsystem wurde aktiviert. Das ist das, was ein Imfunkun soll und äh das sind sozusagen genau die zu erwartenden Effekte und es wäre eher bedenklich, wenn die nicht eintreten.
Ähm gibt's natürlich immer so diese Angst, na ja, was ist, wenn mich das irgendwie langfristig krank macht und keine Ahnung. Dann fall ich sechs Monate später vom vom Stuhl und die Impfung äh war schuld. Und er äh legt es sehr unterhaltsam. Da,
ohne es jetzt lächerlich zu machen und klärt vor allem erstmal mit diesem Begriff Langzeitfolgen,
bisschen äh räumt den erstmal ein bisschen äh äh weg, weil das, was man beim Impfen als Langzeitfolgen bezeichnet,
das sind Dinge, die so bis maximal nach sechs Wochen nach der Impfung auftreten. Das ist so dieser Zeitraum, den man sich anschaut.
Ja und danach ist eigentlich selten was, also wann auch immer es bei
ähm Impfungen, Probleme gab oder nimmt als Beispiel die Impfung gegen die Schweinegrippe
da äh gab's den Fall, dass bei manchen geimpften so eine Nakolepsie, so diese Schlafkrankheit auftrat. Also es war irgendwie einer von sechzehntausend, ja. Man hat aber nur von zweitausend, mit zweitausend Leuten getestet.
Der Impfstoff wurde relativ schnell äh zugelassen. Da trat das dann halt irgendwie auf. Das war dann immer noch relativ wenige. Aber es tritt dann halt innerhalb von sechs Wochen auf.
Was danach dann nicht auftritt.
Tritt dann meistens auch gar nicht mehr auf. Also es gibt keine Fälle von Monate oder Jahre nach einer Impfung hast du auf einmal äh irgendeine Wirkung, die sich darauf zurück äh.
Für diese, ne.
Ja, sehr schön. Mhm. Sehr schön.
Diesen schönen äh Spruch noch gebracht. Äh man muss sich immer klar machen, dass diese.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit jetzt durch eine Impfung in irgendeiner Form Problem zu bekommen. Wenn man die jetzt mal vergleicht mit der Wahrscheinlichkeit jetzt hier eine Infektion sich einzufangen und davon.
Zu sterben oder überhaupt negative Auswirkungen zu haben, äh steht in keinem Verhältnis und sagt dann so schön, für dein Don't like the Cure trized the sees.
Man, dass, das äh brachte bei mir dann auch so das Bild vor Augen nach dem Motto, okay. Also hier,
Du kannst dich jetzt entscheiden, wenn du dich immunisieren lassen möchtest, hier hast du eine standardisierte, erprobte,
Impfung mit.
Die ja geprüft ist mit einer standardisierten Dosis. Auf der anderen Seite hast du halt jetzt dieses Virus, was ähm,
im Prinzip erstmal auch grundsätzlich dieselben Auswirkungen hat oder dieselben Proteine oder noch viel mehr Proteine produziert,
wie jetzt im Impfstoff drin sind, nur dass die Dosis, die du dann am Ende bekommst, ein ziemliches
Glücksspiel ist. Das ist dann so, wie du hättest, okay, hier ist der Standardimpfstoff, aber hier kannst du jetzt noch einen anderen Impfstoff,
wo wir jetzt nicht wissen, in welcher Konzentration das Ganze vorliegt. Wir wissen, da ist wahrscheinlich genug drin, aber die Dosis kann eine Million mal höher sein, als in dem standardisierten Impfstoff, ja.
So also es ist ja, wie gesagt, wenn äh tatsächlich ja also Leute, die Angst vor der Impfung haben, äh aber nicht äh vor dem Corona Virus, das ist.
Einfach mal ja selber dem Motto okay, der Virus ist ja natürlich und die Impfung ist künstlich so, als ob es in der Natur keine.
Tödlichen Gifte äh gebe oder pathogene äh äh ja tatsächlich ist die Natur so äh und die Evolution äh einfach der.
Potenteste Hersteller von tödlichen Substanzen, die wir uns äh so überhaupt vorstellen.
Genau, Natur ist nämlich gefährlich.
Genau.
Genau, um da äh die Zahlen vielleicht dann auch nochmal, um das kurz abzuschließen mit diesem Video, was er noch so festhält, ne? Also also dieses Argument auch, dass.
Ist ja jetzt so schnell gegangen sei. Und dass das in irgendeiner Form bedeuten könnte, dass hier nicht gründlich gearbeitet wurde.
Das ist insofern Quatsch, weil äh nicht die Dauer der Testung des Impfstoffes ist entscheidend,
entscheidend mit wie vielen Leuten du getestet hast, also die die Seltenheit ist eigentlich das Problem
wenn du Nebenwirkungen finden willst, dann findest du nicht dadurch besser, dass es irgendwie länger dauert und dass du länger abwartest und länger guckst, weil eben
das meiste tritt sofort auf und das allermeiste äh ist abgeräumt, wenn wenn sechs Wochen, acht, äh, acht Wochen vergangen sind. Die sind jetzt hier schon lange durch
sondern es ist die Frage, wie viele Leute hast du eigentlich in einem Test gehabt und noch nie wurde an so vielen Leuten getestet? Also es gibt keinen Impfstoff,
wo wie mehr als dreißigtausend Leute getestet wurden. Es war teilweise über vierzigtausend. Also es ist schon eine extrem hohe Zahl. Und äh wenn man halt,
viele Leute testen kann und wir haben's halt bei einer Pandemie einfach eben genau damit zu tun gehabt, dass wir in den USA, wo vor allem getestet wurde, Brasilien auch einfach so viele Fälle waren
dass man eben sehr schnell auf diese Zahlen gekommen ist und deswegen konnte man diese Phase drei auch so schnell abschließen.
Schaut euch auf jeden Fall diese Videos an, da ist noch mehr zu holen, also wirklich großartig, ganz toll äh mega make Europe gescheitegan.
Kann ich sehr empfehlen.
Ja, also ja, sehr schön, liked die Quize, die siehst, ja, können wir hier fixen Tride Viros.
Ja, genau. So, zum Abschluss.
Habe ich mir noch ein Thema bereitgelegt, wo ich ehrlich gesagt lange Zeit drüber nachgedacht habe, ob ich das hier überhaupt,
einbringe und ich will dem Ganzen auch gleich mal einen kleinen Disclaimer äh voranstellen. Worum geht's? Es geht um die Frage, Vitamin D,
und Corona.
Werdet ihr sicherlich auch schon mal irgendwas von gehört haben, vielleicht auch nicht, weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung. Ist auf jeden Fall heiß diskutiert,
das auch nicht erst seit Corona,
Weil Vitamin D ist so generell so ein Dauer äh Thema und dementsprechend auch sehr umstritten. Und das hat natürlich auch damit zu tun
Das ist auch viel geschwurbelt drum herum gibt. Also es gibt so
fragwürdige Professoren, die dann wieder irgendwelche Videos rausgebracht haben, denn mit ja hier und Vitamin D,
großartig hilft gegen alles, dass es hier irgendwie die die Universalheilung gegen äh alle möglichen Sachen und dann gibt's natürlich dann auch gleich tausend Verschwörungstheorien dann auch wieder drum herum so oh wenn das irgendwie so,
so ein Wundermittel ist, warum wird uns das vorenthalten.
Was natürlich nicht der Fall ist, weil das Kasse bei Amazon einfach klicken. So, das gibt's. Gibt's einen ausreichenden äh Mengen so, ne? Also was im Raum steht, ist eben die Frage.
Was äh ist die Bedeutung von Vitamin D oder ein konkreter dann Vitamin D drei äh im Zusammenhang mit dieser Coronapanimie hat es irgendwas damit zu tun und wenn ja, was?
Das ist natürlich jetzt eine hochgradig medizinische äh Frage,
und ich kann dazu nur nochmal wiederholen, was wir schon mal äh gesagt haben, ne? Wir so hier als Corona Berater in diesem Podcast
Also wir sind noch nicht mal Informatiker, ja? Also wir geschweige denn in irgendeiner Form
medizinisch ausgebildet, byologisch sonst sowas und so weiter, sondern wir sind einfach nur so zwei alte, weiße Judes, die sich irgendwie Informationen im Internet anschauen und versuchen daraus schlau zu werden und äh ab und zu mal ein paar Zahlen durch Formeln laufen lassen, um sich selber ein Bild zu machen,
Und in irgendeiner Form irgendwas vorzukoinen, wo ihr dann selber euren Zucker zu bauen könnt.
Ja gut, ich habe, ich habe aber auf jeden Fall ab und zu in der Schule aufgepasst.
Ich auch.
Ab und zu, wobei ich eben dazu sagen muss, Chemie gehört definitiv nicht zu meinen Stärken.
Ja ich.
Bio auch nicht
Von daher tue ich mich da jetzt auch ein bisschen schwer. Deswegen stelle ich das auch nochmal äh voran, ja. Ich werde jetzt hier unter Garantie alle Bezeichnungen und Begriffe irgendwie bisschen durcheinander bekommen.
Außerdem meine Primärquelle ist jetzt irgendwie englischer Content und ich kann zwar Englisch, aber definitiv ist medizinisches Englisch jetzt nicht unbedingt meine Spezialisierung.
Und grundsätzlich muss auch vorangestellt werden, hier ärztlicher Rat ist wertvoll, ja? Also ich werde jetzt hier äh keine Empfehlungen abgeben. Ich möchte gerne,
einfach nur mal versuchen zusammenzufassen, was ich jetzt wahrgenommen habe
Äh tatsächlich gibt's auch schon ein interessantes Video von der äh allseits äh bekannten und beliebten Mai äh T, also hier Mylab auf YouTube, weiß nicht, ob du das schon mal gesehen hast.
Zum Thema Vitamin D. Ähm wo sie auch.
Älteres Video oder aktuell.
Nö, das ist gar nicht so alt, das bezieht sich aber jetzt glaube ich nicht äh primär auf äh Corona. Das ist außer das ist sogar sehr aktuell, das ist vom November.
Nee, dann habe ich das noch nicht gesehen.
Genau, so. Wo sie äh ja im Prinzip das auch nochmal die Situation ähnlich zusammenfasst und auch sich Studien anschaut im Wesentlichen so ein bisschen dieses äh nichts genaues weiß man nicht und ähm im Zweifelsfall fragst du mal lieber deinen Arzt,
Ähm.
Das mal so vorweg. So, aber was ich so äh jetzt mir angeschaut habe, fand ich dann doch zu interessant, um um das jetzt hier komplett unter den Tisch fallen zu lassen. Ich will einfach nur sagen, es gibt da,
eine massive,
Forschung, gerade in diesem Bereich. Ähm gerade im Zusammenhang mit Corona, Vitamin D war schon immer interessant, aber äh da geht gerade eine Menge und da kommt am laufenden Meter was raus,
Die Quelle, die ich jetzt hier nenne, ist äh Met Cram, das ist so ein YouTube-Kanal, das ist so ein
Ja, so ein Service, die machen im Wesentlichen so Unterrichtsmaterialien zu medizinischen Themen, das ist so ein bisschen so ihr Ding. Haben aber dann zur Corona Pandemie halt auch so ein Corona Virus-Update quasi gemacht. Dann äh,
was
alle paar Tage hauen die da was raus. Also jetzt ist äh Ende des Jahres, die haben jetzt um die hundertneunzehn Videos allein nur dazu, was gerade rundum Corona quasi auf medizinischer Ebene,
so an neuen Erkenntnissen rausgekommen ist. Schauen sich Studien an, diskutieren das,
medizinischer Kram äh virologische Sachen, andere Aspekte rund um Quit neunzehn, also es ist sehr umfangreich. Ich habe jetzt auch nicht alle gesehen, ich habe mir ein paar,
geschaut, weil ich bin äh über dieses Video erst so richtig auf dieses auf diesen Kanal gekommen, auch wenn ich den vorher schon mal gesehen hatte.
Nummer hundertneunzehn ist also äh Vitamin D und Co wird neunzehn, die Evidence for Prevention and Treatment of Corona Viros.
Und äh das ist auch insofern ein bisschen anders als die anderen Videos, als dass sie das so dialogisch gemacht haben. Das heißt so der Protagonist hier in den meisten Videos, wenn ich das richtig sehe, wenn ich sogar in allen, so Rogers Seehold, das ist halt da so ein Mediziner
der da immer sehr interessant berichtet, lässt sich dann von einem äh anderen Menschen bisschen zu der Situation befragen.
Wie denn sozusagen jetzt der Stand ist, nachdem man sich jetzt ein Jahr lang dieses Thema auch äh immer wieder,
angeschaut hat, um mal so zusammenzufassen, draufzuschauen, so was was wissen wir denn jetzt eigentlich zu diesen zu dieser Fragestellung, Vitamin D drei und Konavirus.
Ja und um da ein bisschen einzuchecken
muss man vielleicht erstmal so ein bisschen und ich beziehe mich jetzt im Wesentlichen aus dem, was ich aus diesem Video gezogen habe, ja? Ich habe ein bisschen nachgelesen und noch mal hier Wikipedia da und so weiter und wie schon gesagt, wird es jetzt wahrscheinlich alles total durcheinander kriegen, aber ich versuch's zumindest mal so grob wiederzugeben, ne? Also was ist
Vitamin D drei, also als Vitamin bezeichnet man ja so Dinge, die als vital für den Körper gelten, ne? Brauchen wir irgendwie, um zu leben? Ähm.
Aber es unter Umständen ein bisschen knifflig ranzukommen, müssen wir halt irgendwie über Nahrung oder andere Wege aufnehmen.
Oder in irgendeiner Form produzieren lassen und der Name kommt glaube ich von irgendwie diesen vitalen Armin und aber nicht alles was heute Vitamin ist, ist,
irgendwie meine ich im Sinne ein Armin. Äh Vitamin D drei ist also technisch eigentlich mehr so ein Hormon,
und beeinflusst sozusagen wie unser Körper funktioniert und das hat vor allem für den Knochenbau halt äh eine eine Bedeutung, ne? Also Vitamin.
Brauchst du einfach, damit der Knochenbau ordentlich äh funktioniert, aber das ist nicht nicht unbedingt die einzige Funktion, die vom.
Vitamin äh die beeinflusst wird. So, da weiß man halt auch teilweise noch nicht unbedingt alles.
Handelt sich hier um etwas, was fettlöslich ist.
Und was deswegen auch in der Lage ist, eben in den Zellkern einzudringen und also nicht nur in die Zelle, sondern auch in den Zellkern und beeinflusst halt auch diesen RNA Produktionsprozess,
und tut das vor allem auch in Immunzellen, die also dafür Rezeptoren haben.
Ähm also man weiß einfach, dass Vitamin D drei in irgendeiner Form auch mit Immunzellen interagiert und Dinge tut,
Wo kommt das jetzt her? Ähm wir als Menschen erzeugen eigentlich Vitamin D aus Sonnenlicht.
Über die Haut. Es ist aber auch in
Tieren, die wir essen drin, bloß nicht besonders viel. Also findest du das irgendwie ein Fischöl, Eigelb, roten Fleisch, manche Pilze, Lebertran hat wohl relativ,
essen wir jetzt nicht unbedingt so täglich, aber so grundsätzlich ist es ein bisschen schwierig, das sozusagen nur über die Nahrung aufzunehmen. Also zumindest jetzt über so natürliche Nahrung aufzunehmen.
Sondern im Wesentlichen ist eigentlich unser Körper dafür zuständig, das selber zu produzieren und das macht er eben durch
UVB strahlen, wenn UVB strahlen halt auf die Haut auftreten, dann wird das so in der Epidermis quasi so aktiviert. Also es gibt immer so Vorstufen, Provitamine
die wir irgendwie im Körper haben und dann eben durch diesen Einfluss von von UVB Strahlung wird dann eben dieses eigentliche Vitamin D äh erzeugt,
und äh wandert dann irgendwie über Blut in die Leber und in der Leber wird es dann nochmal in den eigentlichen, aktiven Stoff, den man dann auch später nachweisen kann oder indem man dieses Level,
wie viel Vitamin D man denn so im Körper hat, dann gemessen werden, umgewandelt. Also es ist sozusagen so ein längerer Prozess. Oder du kannst natürlich so Tabletten kaufen.
Klickst du dir irgendwie so eine kleine Dose, sind dann dreihundertfünfundsechzig Pilzen drin für jeden Tag eine. Sowas gibt's äh relativ günstig zu kaufen und dann kannst du sie einwerfen, dann kriegst du halt im Prinzip denselben Stoff,
ins Blut und dann muss halt auch die Leber äh das Aufnehmen verarbeiten und dann entsprechend in den eigentlichen wirksamen Stoff überführen.
Was machen wohl auch weiß, ist, dass es auch äh durchaus so Sachen gibt, wie zum Beispiel diese Maissirupfruktose, also das was vor allem die Amerikaner da massenhaft in ihre Softdrinks reinballern,
Das sind alles so Faktoren, die ähm auch dazu führen können, dass Vitamin äh die äh deaktiviert wird auf diesem Level. Ja, also es gibt da eine ganze Menge, was man tun kann, um das sozusagen auch alles noch zu verschlimmern,
und äh da es halt auch fettlöslich ist, ist halt auch Gewicht ein Problem. Also hast du viel Fett, dann kann halt das Vitamin D auch da drin verschwinden, ohne dass es irgendwie groß äh genutzt wird.
Aber das Hauptproblem ist erstmal, dass wir halt im Winter einfach nicht genug Licht abkriegen.
Dieses UVB trifft einfach dann nicht mehr in ausreichender Menge auf, dazu kommt natürlich, dass wir so in unseren Lebensweisen,
eh nur sieben bis acht Prozent unserer Zeit uns draußen aufhalten und ansonsten drin sind und es ist derzeit auch nicht unbedingt sehr viel besser geworden, ne?
Und dann auch noch den Großteil der Haut bedeckt halten, wenn wir da.
Genau, das sind dann noch was.
Gibt ja dann auch noch so religiös und sonst wie kultisch äh motivierte Bekleidungsvorschriften, die äh auch nicht unbedingt gerade hilfreich sind. Also das ist, das ist ein anerkanntes Problem und das trifft uns halt dann im Winter,
Und zwar trifft uns besonders dann im Winter, wenn wir in einem Land leben, jenseits des fünfunddreißigsten Breitengrades.
Dass es äh sozusagen so ein bisschen so einen Fresh holt, der ähm der hier äh greift.
Und jetzt sehe ich gerade, dass hier irgendwelche Notizen, die ich mir schon mal gemacht habe.
Nicht da sind, dass man mal so ein Gefühl dafür bekommt, wo wir fünfunddreißigste Breitengrad ist.
Das ist so in Europa ist das so die Höhe von von Zypern. Kreta, Zypern,
Nordspitze von Tunesien, das ist so fünfunddreißigster Breitengrad oder auch äh Tokio.
Ähm Los Angeles, Atlanta,
dass es so so diese Ecke. Das betrifft natürlich jetzt, dass jetzt äh die nördliche Hemisphäre, dasselbe gilt natürlich im Prinzip auch für die südliche Hemmesphäre. Da ist es dann aber eher so Sydney und so die Grenze, das heißt,
Da ist dann im Süden ja auch nicht mehr so viel. Also das das Problem existiert im Wesentlichen im Norden.
Und ähm das sind so die Regionen, wo dann einfach im Winter das UVB einfach nicht mehr in dem ausreichendem Maße aufschlägt und dementsprechend.
Ist unsere Fähigkeit, Vitamin D zu erzeugen, halt eingeschränkt. Außerdem äh werden die Körper auch schlechter im Erzeugen von Vitamin D.
Im hohen Alter, ne? Also, du hast wenig die drei.
Vitamin D drei ist so das worum's geht durch wenig Sonnenlicht wenn es zu dick bist und dann können auch so Nierenkrankheiten und so weiter, das kann irgendwie auch noch führen, habe ich vorhin lieber gesagt, ich glaube ich meinte die Niere. Wisst ihr, was meinte ich mit, ich kriege wieder alles durcheinander.
Keine Ahnung von von Medizin. So und ähm ja das äh gibt sozusagen die,
Vermutung, dass wenig Vitamin D drei im Körper die Wahrscheinlichkeit erhöht sich mit so.
Atemwegsernkrankungen zu äh zu infizieren und ähm das ist sozusagen das, was jetzt in diesem Vortrag,
auch nochmal genauer äh abgelesen wird. Also man kann relativ leicht diesen Vitamin D drei Level im Körper feststellen und es gibt so ein paar Fresh Holz
ich will jetzt hier nicht so sehr mit Zahlen agieren, das hilft jetzt eher relativ wenig, aber nehmen wir einfach mal so zur Kenntnis, es gibt so ein so ein, so ein Halbwegs akzeptierten
Menge an Vitamin D im Körper, die man als normal äh und als genug und auch definitiv auch als zu wenig bezeichnen kann.
Und ja jetzt ist sozusagen die Frage was was hat denn das jetzt für Auswirkungen auf uns.
Ähm jetzt wird da eine ganze Batterie von Studien vorgestellt und das rattert irgendwie in einer Geschwindigkeit durch. Ich habe mir das Video dann irgendwie dreimal angeschaut.
Beim ersten Mal dachte ich mir so, oh, was war das denn jetzt, beim zweiten Mal habe ich versucht, so ein bisschen zu verstehen und mitzuschreiben und dann muss sie aber nochmal durchgehen, damit ich das irgendwie,
halbwegs zusammenbekomme und ich bin jetzt auch gerade etwas beunruhigt.
Weil mir ein paar Notizen hier verloren gegangen sind. Ich glaube, ich werde mal aus meiner Erinnerung das nochmal kurz äh zusammenfassen. Also was man generell feststellen kann.
Aus Studien ist Vitamin D drei Level sind ähm.
Abhängig halt von wo du lebst. Das habe ich schon gesagt, ne? Fünfunddreißigster Balkengrad, umso dunkler dein Land,
Umso weniger hast du die Möglichkeit, halt selber Vitamin D äh zu liefern. Das hat auch ein bisschen was damit zu tun, wie viel Vitamin D drei so in deiner Nahrungskette drin ist und es gibt Länder, die fügen das einfach über die normal verkaufte Nahrung mit zu, vor allem über Milch.
Also Linda, die sagen einfach, wir machen Vitamin D drei in die Milch und ihr kauft euch die Milch und schüttet die euch irgendwie in ihr äh in euer Müsli und dann habt ihr irgendwie,
höheren Anteil. Es ist ein Problem mit Alter, aber es ist auch ein Problem mit Hautfarbe und das hängt natürlich dann wieder mit der Lichtgeschichte zusammen,
Ja, also das ist belegt, man weiß, dass es einfach für helle Hautfarben einfacher ist, Vitamin D zu erzeugen, dunkle Hautfarben, Hamster,
schwerer und auch so wie man's erwarten würde, also umso dunkler die Haut, umso weniger wird es äh entsprechend dann,
produziert, also wenn man mit einer dunklen Haut auch noch im Norden lebt, dann trifft's einen sozusagen gleich doppelt.
Na gut, dann beginnt so ein ganzer Reigen und wird jetzt hier äh eine Studie nach der anderen äh vorgestellt, die so für bestimmte Asp
erstmal beleuchten, ne? Äh unter anderem eine Studie aus Deutschland, wo man sich irgendwie fünfzehn Jahre lang Leute angeschaut hat, also sozusagen so eine so eine so eine Beobachtungsstudie und dann einfach mal geguckt hat, so haben wir denn hier irgendwie
Sterblichkeit aus, mit Arten, durch Atemwegsinfektionen,
und ähm da kann man dann schon mal feststellen, aha, okay, es gibt eine geringere Todesrate bei Leuten mit mit eher hohen Vitamin D-Leveln.
Das ist einfach erstmal nur so Feststellung. Ich muss gleich nochmal vorwegstellen, so das ist jetzt erstmal alles in dieser Korrelation, ist nicht Karusation, ja? Also nur weil wir sozusagen dann,
einen zahlenmäßigen Zusammenhang sehen, heißt es nicht, dass es der Grund dafür ist, ne? Aber es ist sozusagen es, es kommt dann relativ viel zusammen.
Sozusagen es könnte so sein, dass sozusagen auch eine äh erhöhte Infektions äh Aktivität äh einfach die Vitamin D äh.
Pegel fallen lässt, dass wir sozusagen auch.
Genau, das ist das ist immer das, was so im Raum steht, ne? Oder oder was ist der Grund oder es könnte natürlich auch noch andere Faktoren geben, ne? Es könnte auch was damit zu tun, äh haben das so im Sommer mehr Eis isst und im Winter äh.
Äh äh mehr Schlittschuhvers oder so, das das ist das Ding, ne? Aber das mal vorweggestellt äh trotzdem ganz interessant, ne? Dann,
kommt zu einem Metastudio ran,
wo sie dann und sind auch wirklich so Studien, die sagen wir mal so üblichen Kriterien erfüllen, die man daran haben will, ne? Also randomisiert und kontrolliert, also mit Placebo-Gruppen und wo man sich das wirklich mal genau.
Anschaut und man hat man sieht schon auch in so Metastudien wo sie also wirklich mehrere,
mehrere Studien ausgewertet haben, äh über über sehr viele Leute, dass halt ähm Vitamin D Level, die die Sterblichkeiten einfach generell äh senkt.
Musste jetzt hier dieser Zahl genau ähm oder man hat auch mal geschaut eine Studie aus Japan.
Ähm wo man sich Schulkinder angeschaut hat, die auch so ein Vitamin D äh Supplement bekommen haben, so.
Also die haben was weiß ich so tausendzweihundert EU, also es gibt ja diese International United, wenn da eine so eine.
So eine so eine Packung kaufst, mit so Pillen hast und normalerweise so kleine Pillchen drin und jede Pille hat so,
eine Menge, die dann in meiner tausend International United, also es ist jetzt so speziell für Vitamin D drei, ist das irgendwie so eine Unit und äh tausend EU hast du so normalerweise da drin
man geht generell davon aus, dass so tausend bis viertausend zu nehmen und wie kein großes Problem ist.
Und ähm die haben halt tausendzweihundert pro Tag bekommen, die Kinder und haben dann halt äh geschaut, okay, wer hat denn jetzt hier im äh im Winter eine Grippe äh bekommen und hat man halt auch gesehen, deutlich mehr,
Kinder haben sich irgendwie eine Grippe eingefangen die als deutlich mehr haben, die sich die Grippe eingefangen, die kein Supplement genommen haben.
Na ja, also das sind alles so so Hinweise da drauf und dann man hat sich das, dann gibt's halt auch äh in zunehmendem Maße jetzt äh Studien, die rauskommen,
eben sich jetzt auch konkret sozusagen anschauen, okay, was ist denn jetzt hier eigentlich mit Kowit und und Vitamin D drei, kann das in irgendeiner Form was miteinander zu tun haben.
Und da sieht man erstmal so generell, dass ähm eine Vitamin D.
Difficiancy, also niedrige Vitamin D drei Versorgung, wenn die vorliegt, ja? Auf welche anderen biochemischen Faktoren hat denn das einen Einfluss, ne? Und dann sieht man, dass.
Das, was sozusagen niedriger Vitamin D Level macht, das schwächt äh,
ähnliche Dinge oder die selben Faktoren, in ähnlichem Maße, wie es auch eine Kowit neunzehn Erkrankung macht.
Ne, also das hat sowas mit diesen Indikatoren zu tun, die man so misst, um so Entzündungen im Körper zu messen und so weiter. Da.
Da bin ich dann auch komplett ausgestiegen, dass dann irgendwie äh nicht meine Baustelle ähm.
Aber man sieht dann eben auch, äh dass eben all das, was sozusagen vorhin, was ich schon genannt habe, weil Vitamin D äh problematisch ist, also für die Produktion von Vitamin D problematisch ist,
auch bei Covit neunzehn ein Problem ist. Es gibt erhöhte äh,
Fallraten bei Leuten mit dunklerer Hautfarbe, ja? Es gibt einen Einfluss von Übergewichtigkeit. Es gibt einen Einfluss,
des Alters ja ganz deutlich, ja? Also da korrelieren die Sachen einfach stark.
Also all das, was sozusagen, weil Vitamin D drei auffällt, fällt auch äh bei Cofit neunzehn auf.
Und das wiederholt sich halt, also es äh was man sich auch anschaut. Man sieht immer, dass dass diese Faktoren da äh,
'ne Rolle haben. Man hat sich das also genau dann gibt's halt auch entsprechende epidemologische Studien, die diese äh Faktoren bei Covet neunzehn Sterbefällen äh untersuchen, da hat man sich zum Beispiel siebzehn Millionen Leute angeschaut, davon irgendwie,
knapp elftausend Leute, die an Code neunzehn gestorben sind und sieht halt äh du hast höhere Sterberaten jetzt bei Covet neunzehn höheres Alter, männlich, Übergewicht, dunkle Hautfarbe.
Äh interessanterweise ähm auch frühere Raucher.
Wir hatten ja mal dieses Raucherthema, du erinnerst dich vielleicht, da waren glaube ich in Frankreich mal so diese
Studie, wo sie sich schon alle so gewundert haben, was sind hier so mit Rauchern und so und die Raucher waren irgendwie gar nicht schlechter gestellt
auch in dieser Studie, die da genannt wird, die ist aus dem Juli zwanzig zwanzig, ist alles relativ aktuell hier. Tatsächlich frühere Raucher haben ein höheres Risiko, aber aktuelle Raucher haben ein niedrigeres Risiko.
Und der äh Moderator der diesen Arzt dann befragt meint er dann auch so, ja ähm
Das kommt mir jetzt aber komisch vor, kann man das hier irgendwie ernst nehmen? Da meinte er so, na ja, also
Das heißt jetzt auf gar keinen Fall, dass ihr irgendwie diese Studie schlecht gemacht wäre und man kann sich das schon irgendwie erklären, weil wohl so Nikotin tatsächlich auch so ein entzündungshemmendes äh.
Gerät ist. Ja, also,
wird irgendwie gegen diese Entzündungsstoffe, kann ich's nicht erklären. Und was weiß ich, erzeugt Stickstoff, Monoxid, was die Blutgefäße erweitert und so weiter. Also es ist durchaus plausibel,
dass man äh feststellt, so ah ja und wie Leute, die gerade die rauchen und permanent dieses Nikotin aufnehmen, dass die tatsächlich.
Gegebenenfalls hier wirklich auch in dieser Studie hat sich das halt in den Zahlen auch gezeigt, ja? Ein niedriges Risiko haben
weil sie quasi sich hier ein Gift aufnehmen, was natürlich an sich schädlich ist für den Körper. Nur konkret eben für Cofit neunzehn unter Umständen durchaus von Vorteil ist, weil du halt irgendwie deine Entzündungen bekämpfst
in dem Moment, wo du irgendwie infiziert bist. Keine Ahnung. Also das kommt zumindest aus dieser Studie bei raus.
Der nee, ich meine, Nikotin greift halt auf ziemlich niedriger Ebene in den Stoffwechsel ein. Das ist so dieser ganze, ich sage mal,
Nikotin, Adin, Diphosphat oder so äh spielt halt also auch in der Natur eine wilde wichtige Rolle und ja insofern ist da,
einiges möglich. So.
Ja, so geht das dann eigentlich äh weiter. Also man schaut sich auch so, dann gibt's eine Studie aus dem April, die dann auch mal so äh diese,
Länder, also diese Statistiken gemacht hat, Motalität nach äh Ländern, wobei das halt so der März ist, äh der da quasi nur mit reinfließt.
Aber auch da sieht man schon so,
Länder jenseits von fünfunddreißig Grad haben irgendwie ein Problem, was Länder äh innerhalb dieses fünfunddreißiger Rings so nicht in dem Maße haben.
Grundsätzlich natürlich bei äh Vitamingaben. Wir hatten ja auch vor Jahren mal,
Leute, die sich extrem hohe Dosen, Vitamin C äh verabreicht, haben so nach dem Motto viel hilft viel und äh das.
Kann man aber bei Vitaminen definitiv sagen, dass ist nicht der Fall, sondern im Gegenteil, so praktisch,
jedes Vitamin in zu hohen Dosen kann halt giftig sein,
und äh bei Vitamin D kann man zwar relativ hoch hinausgehen, aber das ist nicht so, dass äh man nicht auch äh sich da eine Überdosis äh geben,
kann und dann äh ja die die Folgen, also von Vitamin D Toxizität sind dann halt auch nicht schön so wie äh ja,
Wassermangel, äh Übelkeit, Erbrechen durch Fall.
Reizbarkeit, Verstopfung, Müdigkeit und ja Muskelschwäche und so gehören halt dazu, aber äh die kommen halt nicht direk,
überwiegend, weil man dann zu viel Vitamin D hat, sondern weil das dann mit anderen Vitaminenwechsel wirkt von denen dann zu wenig da sind. So, aber vielleicht kann man ja grundsätzlich,
erstmal sagen ähm so ähm ich kann.
Glaube ich ganz gut nachvollziehen, dass wenn Vitamin D fehlt,
dass das anfälliger macht, dass das Immunsystem nicht so gut funktioniert und und und. Aber sagen der Umkehrschluss, dass je mehr äh Vitamin D äh man sich äh davon.
Äh umso äh besser fährt man. Da gibt's definitiv dann.
Grenze und bei den Studien, so wie ich das sehe hier mit teilweise größenordnungen von irgendwie.
Achtzigtausend oder sogar zweihunderttausend internationale Einheiten. Das liegt schon in der Größenordnung, wo man dann auch schon.
Toxizität oder Überdosen beobachtet hat, so ab achtzigtausend wohl ungefähr
geht das dann langsam los, wobei so 'ne
akute Überdosis irgendwie zwischen sechshunderttausend und eins Komma sechs Millionen Einheiten liegt also mit anderen Worten äh ja war jetzt nicht super gefährlich, was sie gemacht haben, aber,
das war schon an der obersten Grenze dessen, was man verabreichen kann.
Ja, man muss dabei, man muss da unterscheiden, also es gab relativ klar so diese Aussage äh ist nicht so, dass du jetzt sozusagen so eine Überdosis davon nehmen kannst
Ja, weil wenn du jetzt sozusagen so eine große Menge umsetzt, das muss ja vom Körper auch umgesetzt werden
da wird dann einfach der Großteil auch einfach ignoriert. Sondern es ist sozusagen sehr viel stärker eine Frage von kontinuierlicher Überdosierung,
Also es ist nicht so, du nimmst jetzt irgendwie so die Überdosis, äh, Vitamin D drei und dann kippst du um, sondern dass er ähm gab dann zum Beispiel eine Studie, die Zahl, die du jetzt gerade zitierst, da haben sie halt einfach jetzt,
in Studien probiert, so okay, was was könnte das jetzt hier bringen? Haben dann irgendwie mal versucht, mit einer äh du einmaligen Dosis von zweihunderttausend EU irgendwas zu erreichen und hatten genau gar keine andere Wirkung als Placebo.
Sozusagen der Körper das einfach äh weggeworfen hat. Aber bei anderen Studien, wo sie dann eben,
ähm mit moderateren Dosierungen gearbeitet haben, aber so was weiß ich die achtzigtausend, die du zitiert hast, war dann alle zwei bis drei Monate, ja? Hat dann durchaus zu höheren Überlebensraten,
geführt. Und das bringt uns jetzt eigentlich auch schon genau in diesen zweiten Bereich. Also was ich jetzt vorher eigentlich gesagt habe, ist so dieses,
sehr viele Studien, die immer wieder diese selbe Bild liefern, einerseits
der Körper mit Kovic zu kämpfen hat und was eine Unterversorgung von Vitamin D drei generell im Körper äh bewirkt oder womit es einhergeht, ist irgendwie sehr vergleichb,
und diese eigentliche Frage ist ja
hilft's irgendwas. Und das ist so, es gibt aber jetzt mittlerweile auch eben eine Reihe von Interventionsstudien, also wo man wirklich mal Vitamin D drei genommen hat und gesagt hat, okay jetzt gucken wir mal, ob wir damit auch irgendwas verbessern können
Und ähm gibt's eine eine spanische Studie aus dem Oktober, die relativ viel Aufmerksamkeit erzeugt hat, wo sie dann tatsächlich bei
neunzehn Patienten im Krankenhaus, den es halt schlecht ging? Äh,
Vitamin D drei zugeführt haben und zwar nicht so wie ich das jetzt bisher gesagt habe so als Supplement.
Isst, sondern die haben dann vermutlich gespritzt bekommen direkt die,
drei Variante bekommen wie sie letztlich im Körper vorliegt, nachdem deine Niere die metabolisiert hat.
Nee, das wird schon die Leber gewesen sein, eher die Nierf. Mhm.
Äh ja die Lieber ähm,
wie gesagt, es bringt alles so durcheinander, ne? Äh ähm das heißt dann Kalzifiol oder Fädiol und ähm.
Das wurde sozusagen den äh äh direkt gespritzt und hatte sehr positive Effekte, ja? Also sie mussten dann sozusagen von den Patienten nur zwei Prozent äh noch in die,
intensiv Abteilung äh schicken. Während in der Placebo-Gruppe halt fünfzig Prozent äh.
Intensiv betreut werden musste. Also es gibt schon so interessante erste Indikationen, dass man eben jetzt mit Vitamin D drei auch akut da äh was helfen kann. Und da da würde jetzt einfach,
ausprobiert, ne, sowohl mit Langzeit
Vorsorge, dass man eben Leuten wirklich in solchen Studien regelmäßig bestimmte Dosierungen über einen längeren Zeitraum paar Tage oder eben auch alle paar Monate was gibt und dann eben schaut, was hat das so für Auswirkungen auch im Heilungs
Prozess. Gibt da was in Indien, wo sie irgendwie mit glaube ich vierzig äh Cover neunzehn,
positiven, den so sechzigtausend EU äh täglich gegeben haben, eine relativ hohe Dosis und das führte dann auch dazu, dass eben mehr Leute als in der Kontrollgruppe äh wieder negativ wurden. Also quasi auch wirklich diese Krankheit dann überwunden haben.
Also das.
Ist so ein Schema und es ist wirklich eine Vielzahl von von Studien, die halt vorgestellt wird, wo man sich dann halt am am Ende fragen kann, ja okay, gut, ähm,
Was bringt mir das jetzt sozusagen, ne? Und dem Ganzen
weil es eben schon diesen Aspekt dieser Toxizität äh gibt, die du angesprochen hast. Man hat generell sagen muss, dass wenn man jetzt sozusagen über sich selber nachdenkt, ist es,
Erstmal so die Frage, ja okay, was habe ich denn eigentlich für ein Level? Also bin ich eigentlich unterversorgt oder nicht? Und das kann man natürlich jetzt so allgemein überhaupt nicht,
beantworten. Das ist das, was man irgendwie beim Arzt feststellen kann. Ich denke mal, wenn man so ein so einen Standard-Check-Up durchführen lässt, dann sagst du hier, nimm mal meine Werte, gehört, glaube ich, dieser Vitamin D drei Wert auch dazu,
Weiß ich nicht genau, aber äh so meine Vermutung und dann kann man sich sozusagen da auch konkret mal.
Beraten lassen, beziehungsweise weiß überhaupt erstmal, wo man ist. Aber andererseits werden ja auch diese.
Also scheint es schon so ein Konsens zu sein, dass so eine Zuführung von tausend bis viertausend pro Tag ähm.
Auch allgemein als unproblematisch gilt. Also wo auch gesagt wird, sonst
muss jetzt nicht zum Arzt rennen, irgendwie, also ob sowas hilft, kann man denen nicht sagen, aber ist auf jeden Fall jetzt auch nicht so, dass es dich umbringt. Äh wenn du nicht irgendwelche Krankheiten äh hast, die an der Stelle vielleicht ungünstig sind.
Und ja er meinte dann noch Faulschi machte es auch.
Was ich so.
Und der selber auch, ja.
Und was ich so sehe ist, dass zumindest bei Erwachsenen viertausend Einheiten ähm äh pro Tag äh also bis zu viertausend pro Tag als unbedenklich gelten.
Genau und dann musst du auch nochmal gegenrechnen, also wenn du wenn du jetzt sozusagen übergewichtig bist, dann ist geht sozusagen nochmal mehr verloren.
Also der Effekt, man hat dann auch mal gemessen, okay, wenn ich so und so viel supplementiere
Wie sehr bringt denn das mein Pegel auch nach oben? Hat man gemerkt, so Leute, die halt mit einem BMI von fünfundzwanzig bis dreißig unterwegs waren,
mussten schon irgendwie die anderthalbfache äh Menge nehmen, um irgendwie denselben Effekt zu haben und Leute, die jenseits von BMI dreißig sind, sogar wie fast das Dreifache
Was leicht erklärbar ist, ne, weil mehr Fett da, wo es reingehen kann und das bleibt dann halt da einfach hängen.
Genau, also was lässt sich sozusagen mitnehmen. Man kann also einfach sagen, es es gibt da viel Korrelationen, wo man sich noch ein bisschen unklar,
drüber zu sein scheint es, ob das auf Infektion überhaupt eine eine Auswirkung haben kann, ne? Also,
kann es überhaupt sozusagen verhindern, dass ich mich überhaupt infizieren kann? Ist unklar, gibt so verschiedene äh Untersuchungen.
Tendenz eher bei bei Infektionen wahrscheinlich eher nicht so sehr, oder?
Weiß ich nicht. Also es war eine Studie dabei, wo das sozusagen äh auch eine eine Auswirkung gezeigt hat, aber da bin ich jetzt auch ein bisschen Lost in Data. Äh aber was glaube ich relativ.
Deutlich wird es, es gibt schon einen Einfluss auf Krankheitsverläufe. Also da läuft irgendwas, ja? Und ähm.
Bewiesen ist hier äh noch nichts, aber äh lohnt sich auf jeden Fall diese Forschung noch weiter voranzutreiben.
Ja, man kann, glaube ich, sagen, es kann auf jeden Fall nicht schaden sagen auf seinen Vitaminen,
Pegel zu achten und äh einen Vitamin Defizit zu vermeiden, scheint auch äh ganz klar dann äh zu helfen, äh falls man den,
erkrankt an äh Kowitt äh so.
Das ist meine Vermutung
Also das ist so ein bisschen das, was ich jetzt hier rausziehe so und dann kann ja jeder mal für sich selber die Rechnung aufmachen so, was habe ich für ein äh
Was habe ich für ein Geschlecht? Also Männer sind ja auch generell nochmal schlechter gestellt als Frauen mit der Ausnahme von Schwangeren, bei denen es ja auch problematisch ist. Das kann halt auch was genau mit dieser ganzen Hormonisierung zu tun haben
und wenn man im Land lebt, was halt nicht Vitamin D drei generell schon über die Milch ausschüttet, da weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht genau, wie das in in Deutschland so ist.
Ein Deutschland nicht in USA, ja, steht halt immer auf der Packung äh drauf. Ähm.
Okay,
Genau, aber hier ist nicht jeden Tag Fisch esse und Lebertran äh trinke, so kann man davon ausgehen, dass man im Winter, wenn man sowieso viel drin ist, äh einfach äh wenig Chancen hat
da äh Großwasser in seinem Level zu machen. Ist natürlich so, dass wenn man jetzt einen sonnigen Sommer gehabt hat,
Ja und was weiß ich den ganzen Sommer bei dreißig Grad äh nackt rumgelaufen ist. Das reichert sich ja dann sozusagen auch im Fett an. Also dafür ist das Fett ja dann auch äh da, ne?
Damit sozusagen die Winterversorgung sicherzustellen.
Aber ja in der aktuellen Situation ist es vielleicht ganz sinnvoll, da nochmal ein bisschen nachzulegen.
Also da würde mich jetzt auch wirklich freuen, wenn ihr zuhört und ihr habt irgendwie mehr Ahnung als von Medizin als ich,
Das ist nicht schwierig. Äh wenn ihr euch mal dieses Video anschauen würdet oder mal eure Meinung.
Zu Geblauben scheint das auf jeden Fall ein spannendes Feld zu sein, wo gegebenenfalls demnächst noch mehr von hören werden.
Also ich denke auf jeden Fall also die also es gibt eine große Zahl von Studien, die relativ.
Deutliche Ergebnisse ausweist, was ja dem Einzelnen dann noch immer nicht,
ja die absolute Wahrheit sein muss aber doch die die Indizien sind auch sehr stark und.
Muss auch dazu sagen, es ist jetzt auch nicht überraschend, dass ein Vitamin D Mangel nicht,
Also es wäre eher.
Es würde mich eher verwundern, wenn es jetzt keine Probleme machen, wenn wir jetzt rausgekommen wäre, aha spielt die gar keine Rolle, wie hoch der Vitamin D Pegel ist, das wäre für mich erstaunlicher,
al
so äh was jetzt bei den bei den Studien äh rauskommt und ich glaube der eigentliche Frage.
Ist so kann man mit hohen Dosen vielleicht ja ein gutes Ergebnis erreichen und da ist,
eher die Frage noch offen beziehungsweise da ist auch klar, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass Vitamin D jetzt einen direkter.
Viruskiller ist oder so, es ist Virus Vitamin D nicht mag, sondern es ist halt ein Bestandteil ein
wichtiges Mittel, das im Immunsystem und an anderen Stellen benötigt wird, um eine vernünftige Immunantwort zu formulieren, aber eine jetzt auch.
Sagen ähm.
Mein Auto fährt halt mit halb vollem Tank genauso schnell wie mit vollem Tank, ja? Und es bringt jetzt überhaupt nichts, wenn ich jetzt äh ja,
keine Ahnung, nochmal tausend Liter äh Sprit irgendwo ein Fülle,
ja davon das das bringt's jetzt auch nicht davon. Fährt's halt jetzt nicht schneller so.
Und.
Immer davon aus, ähnlich sieht's bei Vitaminen die aus, äh wenn einfach andere Stoffe, die halt jetzt auch gebraucht werden, beziehungsweise die Zahl der Zellen, die überhaupt
da sind um irgendetwas zu tun, die ist ja auch begrenzt insofern. Ja.
Richtig. Den Benzinvergleich Zitrois äh Maiti in ihrem Video auch. Ohne dass du das jetzt äh gesehen hast.
Nee, habe ich nicht. Äh also die Benzinvergleich kam jetzt äh tatsächlich äh äh gerade auch äh sagen, ja.
Genau, also noch ist noch einiges mehr äh äh drin in dem in dem Video zu finden. Da äh sagt er noch was äh dazu, wie das so ist mit äh der Dosierung, also ne.
Habe ich glaube ich schon erwähnt, also wenn man jetzt regelmäßig eine gewisse Menge aufnimmt, so, dann dann steigert sich schon äh
diese Insuffizienz oder dann nimmt diese Insuffizienz auch schon deutlich ab, aber umso mehr man sozusagen drauflegt, umso geringer ist auch dieser Effekt, ja? Also es gibt relativ wenig Indikationen für große Probleme
Und auch so dieses
diese Frage, die ja so ein bisschen im Raum steht, so ja okay, also wenn Vitamin D und und Covit neunzehn irgendwie so korrigieren kann, es halt vielleicht auch sein, dass dass das irgendwie die Krankheit selber sozusagen auch diesen Immun äh
äh diesen diesen äh die drei Anteil senkt so und gibt's auch Studien, die das sagen, aber.
Da tut es aber nur in sehr geringen Maße, das erklärt diese Effekte insgesamt nicht. Also das ist auf jeden Fall was für Wissenschaftler und Mediziner
aber äh ich war erstaunt, wie viel da äh gemacht wird und vor allem auch wie viel Studien zu diesem Thema in den letzten Monaten allein schon rausgekommen sind. Also wer das verfolgen will
Würde mich auch mal interessieren, was ihr von diesem Metram Channel äh haltet. Ich fand das ganz äh instruktiv, ganz hilfreich.
Ja, damit werden wir dann am Ende dieser Sendung angekommen, Pavel.
Ja
Sozusagen schon Zeit für den Ausblick.
Ja Ausblick, also.
Das hat jetzt alle verunsicher.
Es ist.
Mhm.
Also äh okay, vielleicht dann jetzt mal einen ein paar gewagte Prognosen oder ich meine, jede Prognose ist.
Gewagt äh mehr oder weniger gewagt, äh was äh jetzt Kowit angeht, ist es immer für Überraschungen gut. Aber ich glaube, wir können erstmal festhalten und.
Zum Beispiel auch der Altmaier gesagt, also am zehnten Januar wird da Lockerungstechnisch.
Eher gar nichts passieren und ähm,
Ich rechne damit, dass wir erstmal jetzt Zahlenchaos haben werden, dass wir uns nicht sicher sein können, wie wie läuft's denn jetzt gerade? Äh aber dass wir ja jetzt.
Über die nächsten zwei Wochen wild hin und her springende Tageszahlen haben werden, dass wir an einem.
Also noch mehr als sonst.
Noch mehr als sonst, dass wir an einem Tag dann vielleicht fünfmal so viele Zahlen wie an einem anderen Tag haben werden und dass sich das dann ganz äh auch erstmal setzen und stabilisieren muss.
Bis wir genau wissen, ob's jetzt sinkt oder oder steigt, aber eigentlich müsste jetzt die Tatsache.
Dass Ferien sind, das halt die Schulen.
Na ja, geschlossen. Man kann auch eigentlich auch nicht von geschlossenen Schulen reden, weil viele Schulen sind ja noch auf, da kann man dann trotzdem seine Kinder zur Aufbewahrung abgeben, äh so wie ich das gehört habe.
Also jetzt nicht während der Weihnachtsferien, aber.
Ja, aber äh sagen.
Weil sie in den Sperrungen so gewesen, ja.
Sozusagen außerhalb jetzt der der Ferienzeiten insofern ja gut jetzt Weihnachten.
Also glaube ein paar Verkehrsdaten
deuten jetzt darauf hin, dass die Leute sich schon zurückgehalten haben auch im Gegensatz zur früheren Jahren, mit dem nach Hause fahren und so sechzig Prozent weniger Zugverkehr an Weihnachten
und alles andere muss man jetzt sehen, ich denke auch, dass ja.
Am wahrscheinlichsten ist es, dass es sich wie mehr oder weniger seitlich jetzt erstmal weiterentwickelt, dass wir jetzt,
erstmal mehr oder weniger auf dem aktuellen Level verharren. Ich gehe jetzt ein bisschen runter, vielleicht geht's ein bisschen rauf, aber so.
Wirklich jetzt krasse Änderungen, werden wir werden wir nicht.
Sehen in den nächsten zwei, drei Wochen ähm würde ich einschätzen und.
Dann wird es auch eine langsamer und zäher Kampf der über Monate sich fortsetzen wird mit viel zu hohen Zahlen an Toten noch mit.
Viel zu vielen Infektionen ja ähm und.
In dem Moment, wo wir lockern werden, aber vielleicht auch sogar vorher, weil ob wir jetzt offiziell gelockert wird oder die Leute für sich beschließen, wir haben jetzt keinen Bock mehr, je nachdem was früher ähm.
Auftritt äh so werden die Zahlen natürlich nach oben gehen. Es könnte auch sein, dass wir nochmal eine Runde von Verschärfungen zwischendurch kriegen. Also es nochmal drauf gelegt wird,
vielleicht von den fünf Seiten Ausnahmen vielleicht noch ein paar gestrichen,
werden, äh, die wir da jetzt in Berlin haben in der Korona Schutzverordnung, das will ich jetzt auch nicht.
Ausschließen wollen, ja. Also die anderen wollten, wir werden wahrscheinlich weder jetzt ein.
Hochschießen der.
Der Zahlen auf, weiß ich nicht, fünfzig oder hunderttausend pro Tag sehe ich nicht, aber ich sehe auch die fünfzig pro hunderttausend.
Im Moment nur in weiter weiter Entfernung und einfach aus dem Grund, wenn man sich die Mechanik anguckt.
Um wie viel man den R Wert senken müsste,
sehe ich einfach dieses Ersenkungspotential nicht in den Maßnahmen, auch die wir bisher,
beschlossen haben, ne. So, das ist, also weil wir hatten vorher schon einen Haufen.
Maßnahmen die ganze Zeit über und das, was wir draufgelegt haben jetzt zweimal, einmal Anfang November und einmal jetzt so hektisch, panisch kurz vor Weihnachten.
So dass waren jetzt alles nicht so die die großen Hammer, so die also für sich sagen wir.
Bringen die zwischen null Komma eins und null Komma drei weniger auf den auf den R Wert, aber.
Weil wir halt so spät.
Dran sind und äh weil wir's in der falschen Reihenfolge gemacht haben, statt erst hart und dann leicht war halt erst leicht und dann verschärft, dass es dann natürlich auch weniger wirksam. Insofern, ja, rechne ich damit.
Dass wir in den nächsten Wochen einen harten Kampf haben werden, um die Zahlen,
überhaupt nur in etwa da zu halten, wo sie jetzt sind und viel weiter hoch, dürfen sie auch nicht mehr. So, weil äh ja,
vielen Gegenden.
Die äh Krankenhäuser einfach schon am Limit oder drüber hinaus in deutschlandweit noch nicht, wahrscheinlich kommt man nochmal,
Ja nochmal eine Verdopplung oder Verdreifachung wahrscheinlich äh wegstecken der.
Belastung aber.
Irgendwo zwischen dem zwei und dreifachen liegt dann auch der komplette Zusammenbruch der dann ja aber ziemlich sicher nicht kommen wird oder wenn dann werden wir ihn nur regional erleben.
Erleben ihn teilweise jetzt schon regional, wobei es jetzt noch die Möglichkeit gibt, im Moment in andere Gegenden, die Leute äh zu transferieren, äh was auch an vielen Stellen,
erfolgt und nötig ist. Ja so viel zur Situation äh wie ich sie im Moment.
Einschätze.
Ja, ich denke das Potential für weitere Verschärfung ist begrenzt. Ich glaube, dass einerseits.
Äh ist nicht genug ähm,
nicht genug Bereitschaft gibt und nicht zu viel nicht genug politische Kreativität ist, wie man sozusagen,
in der aktuellen Situation noch weitere Verschärfungen verkauft und definiert, weil man immer diese gegenläufige Angst hat mit oh Gott, wenn wir jetzt irgendwie unsere Wirtschaft zu sehr einquetschen, dann wird es äh
zu teuer und dann dann finden wir auch die Akzeptanz nicht dafür und äh hat das andere politische Kollateralschäden.
Aber das ist, wie gesagt, nach der, wie sagt man, Nachrichtenlage, Theorie, in dem Moment, wo sich wirklich flächendeckend jetzt äh ja.
Leute auf den Gängen in den Krankenhäusern stapeln oder davor und du halt dann, ja, wieder massenhaft Bilder von Kühlcontainern und Massengräbern äh hast, so, dann.
Ist erstens ist es Alternativlos irgendwas zu tun und die Leute reagieren dann aber natürlich auch alle,
auf äh solche Bilder, das heißt ähm es gibt da meiner Meinung schon ein sich selbst begrenzenden Mechanismus, der zwar jetzt nicht.
Ähm Dinge im Vorfeld verhindert, aber zumindest äh verhindert, dass sie so,
komplett außer äh Kontrolle geraten.
Kann gut sein, die Frage ist nur, wann das stattfinden wird, ne? Wenn das jetzt sozusagen etwas ist, sagen wir mal,
wir sehen jetzt, sagen wir mal, positive Auswirkungen von diesem ähm Dezember Weihnachtslockdown. Ne, also Mobilität geht zurück.
Wir haben jetzt in den Zahlen,
erste Anzeichen für Verlangsamung gesehen, von dem wir nicht wissen, ob wir sie in einer Woche bestätigen werden oder sagen, das war alles nur Pustekuchen und äh schon falsch gemeldete Zahlen, ja?
Kann, kann sehr gut sein, kann aber auch sein, dass es ein bisschen runter geht. Dann haben wir vielleicht.
In der Mitte so eine weitere Seitwärtsbewegung, wie wir sie im Prinzip schon den ganzen November haben. Das heißt, blöde Situation.
Wird bisschen schlechter oder bisschen besser, aber grundsätzlich ändert sich nichts so und an den toten Zahlen sage ich mal so ganz äh Frivol.
Hat man sich dann schon gewöhnt so und dann findet man das aber generell scheiße und man meint auch irgendwas dagegen zu tun zu müssen, aber es wird halt im Wesentlichen einfach erstmal diskutiert,
findet sozusagen nicht die richtigen Maßnahmen,
Dann hast du noch diese gegenläufige Bewegung mit den Impfungen, die dann anfangen. Ne, das hat man ja vorhin schon erwähnt so, jetzt geht's auf die Achtzigjährigen und auf die Siebzigjährigen. Das heißt, du nimmst dann auch einen zunehmenden Maße die potenziellen Hauptopfer raus.
Was dann auch wieder so ein den Druck von von dieser äh Wahrnehmung nimmt, ne? Selbst wenn's noch nicht passiert ist, ist so dieses Jahr wie so die werden da jetzt alle geimpft.
Wobei sich das zahlenmäßig da hängt jetzt auch sehr stark davon ab, wie schnell Impfstoffe verfügbar äh sind und so. Aber ich rechne nicht mit großen Auswirkungen vom März äh durch die Impfungen.
Nee, ich auch nicht, aber die Erwartungen, dass es Auswirkungen haben könnte, die hast du dann unter Umständen schon drin und die arbeitet jetzt im Kopf gegenläufig. Ich habe jetzt sozusagen nicht auf, wie es tatsächlich laufen wird, sondern wie.
Guter Punkt.
Sagen die Bevölkerung das selber so sieht so, ne?
Nach dem nach dem Motto okay, jetzt haben wir ja einen Impfstoff, jetzt ist es ja nicht alles nicht mehr ganz so schlimm, jetzt können wir uns.
Genau, jetzt müssen wir nur noch vier Wochen so weitermachen wie bisher und dann wird es auch automatisch besser,
auch wenn das nicht wirklich eigentlich dazu beiträgt, dass es äh besser wird. Und deswegen würde ich sagen,
Meine Erwartung derzeit, ich wäre gerne eines Besseren belehrt
ist. Wir haben so eine Seitwärtsbewegung. Wir werden uns irgendwie mit diesem Zustand arrangieren. Wir haben so eine kollektive Hoffnung, dass es dann im März durch besseres Wetter
Weiter verbreiteten Impfstoff und magische Wunder äh noch besser wird,
und das, dass wir uns dann irgendwie so in den Sommer gerettet bekommen und dann ist es dann irgendwann so im Juni äh so weit, dass äh so viele Leute geimpft wurden, dass es dann auch wirklich besser wird.
Also nicht schön.
Nur ein wichtiger Punkt, den ich noch vergessen hatte bei sagen der, der Gefahreneinschätzung auch jetzt durch.
Professor Christian Drosten, der so ein bisschen beruhigt hat und dann gesagt hat, na ja.
Virus verbreitet sich nur, wenn es sich auch verbreitet. So, wenn die Zahlen auf dem Weg nach unten sind, hat auch die neue Variante keine gute Chance jetzt.
Raum zu fassen. So, aber das bedeutet natürlich im Umkehrschluss, in dem Moment, wo die Zahlen dann nach oben gehen, ähm.
Gehen die neuen infektiöseren Varianten.
Eben auch mit nach oben und dann stärker mit nach oben und bei diesen Plus null Komma fünf für die neue Variante kann es ganz gut sein, wenn die in irgendeiner Stadt München, Berlin, Hamburg ähm,
dann.
Höhe geht wird wahrscheinlich eher sein wie bei wie bei London. Dann kann's sein, dass wir dann nochmal März und April nochmal so eine richtige Monsterwelle
erleben könnten, die alles bisher da gesehen in den Schatten stell.
Das sind unsere schönen Ausblicke für Weihnachten, für euch, fürs neue Jahr.
Da kann man so sagen, guten Rutsch ähm wobei, na ja, weiß ich gar nicht. Wann machen wir denn unsere nächste Sendung?
Der nächste Freitag ist der erste.
Erstes Jahr könnte man natürlich auch.
Oder halt Palmplatze, irgendwelche Partys.
Also für mich ist das ein Tag wie jeder andere, kann ich dir jetzt schon sagen. Ist es auch sonst eigentlich, normalerweise erhole ich mich äh äh vom Kongress, aber das fällt ja jetzt auch weg. Werden wir sehen. Wir bleiben auf jeden Fall dran, ne?
Ja, wir wir ich würde sagen, wir bleiben einfach im Rhythmus und äh ja.
Dann sind wir sind wir sind wir dran an den Zahlen. Insofern äh guten Rutsch an alle irgendwie das teuflische Jahr ist äh vorbei und es wird definitiv besser, wenn auch nicht gleich sofort.
Ja von mir auch frohes Restfest und das Fest ist ja fast schon vorbei, eigentlich jetzt genau guten Rutsch. Bleibt da noch zu wünschen und.
Gesund.